all right
good morning uh ladies and gentlemen uh
this is the house Judiciary Committee we
have a very full day and I'm going to
begin uh by recognizing representative
trippin asking if he would lead us in
the Pledge of Allegiance
and to the Republic
thank you
so um
ladies and gentlemen I um we have a
really busy day today and we also are
operating under some time constraints
because we have next week is kind of the
last day for us to report so what I'd
like to uh just do at the at the outset
is is kind of set out um is kind of give
everyone an eye an idea of what I
anticipate happening today so first
we're going to have the hearing on the
amendment to HB 533
because we're operating under time
constraints and I know that there are a
number of people who have expressed a
desire to testify I'm going to limit
testimony uh to two minutes each for
every anyone who wishes to testify um
with regard to that
then at 10 o'clock hopefully we will
have the hearing on that done by 10
o'clock we will then turn to Executive
session on the bills that have been
noticed I would note and I do this as
much for for everyone on the committee
as for the um as for the public that
um
at noon time I have to be at a meeting
so we're going to have to take we're
going to recess at noon for about an
hour uh in addition to that
um and I don't know whether this is in
light of the fact that we now have this
hearing I'm not sure whether this is
going to work out or not but
um I would note that at 10 o'clock
um a
um
a local band from Windham New Hampshire
where I'm from and where representative
koutab is also from is playing over uh
in the executive council chambers and
depending upon what's going on and where
we are if I have time uh if I think we
have I have time I may excuse myself and
representative kuta may excuse herself
for just a brief period because we'd
like to we'd like to uh be over to uh
see at least a couple of minutes of that
if possible but it may not be possible
at least for me
um and so that uh
um
I just wanted to sort of let everybody
know where where I was going on that so
with that I'm going to open the uh
hearing uh on HB uh 533 the amendment
and I would recognize uh Diane Fenton
from the Department of Education
foreign
you have somebody with you miss the fan
I do uh good morning
my name is Diana Fenton I'm an attorney
with the Department of Education with me
is uh Richard Farrell who's an
investigator for the Department
I want to be clear as an initial matter
this bill before you this amendment uh
in which requests the Pina power for the
Department of Education for purposes of
conducting
investigations of educator misconduct is
not about commissioner Frank edelblut
it's not for commissioner Frank edelblue
it is for uh investigator Richard
Farrell in order for him to conduct his
investigations
the department has been working very
hard over the past few years to enhance
our child safety initiatives we have
seen various stories in the news
where the department has been working on
on addressing those matters Concord
always comes to mind
um where we are finding Educators who
should not be around children who are
having inappropriate relationships with
children they are few and far between
but they're very very important and
critically important
the code of conduct was passed in 2018
and under that document the department
conducts investigations of educator
misconduct and subpoena power which
other state agencies have in order to
facilitate their investigations oplc as
a point case in point has subpoena power
would help to facilitate that but you
don't have to take my word for it that's
why Richard Farrell is here to speak on
the work that he does
please good morning my name is Richard
Farrell I'm currently employed by the
Department of Education as an
investigator I began this mission on
July 1st 2013. you know Mr Falcon I just
ask you when you I'm not going to
interrupt you now but before you leave
would you just fill out one of the pink
cards yes sir thank you
um I began this mission in July 1st 2013
after serving 30 years as a member of
the New Hampshire State Police before
that I was a licensed educator I spent
three years teaching high school English
and coaching football in Massachusetts
and in a private school in Southern New
Hampshire
at the time of my employment the New
Hampshire New Hampshire relied on
administrative rules to define the
conduct to Define and conduct
investigations into allegations
associated with educated misconduct the
code of conduct didn't exist at all
unfortunately I learned very quickly
that the tools available to me to
complete my assigned cases were very
limited in fact I didn't have any at all
therefore the best approach forward for
me was to make the determined effort to
identify myself to create relationships
with and cultivate trust with the field
this included with superintendents
principals Union attorneys Union reps
attorneys representing school districts
and other stakeholders at first and very
understandably there was skepticism
but I am I'm a person of Irish heritage
and I've been gifted with the ability to
tell people where to go and convince
them to look forward to the trip
you see I had no tools I had no warrants
I had no subpoenas I just had
administrative rules and relationships
I asked Dr Judy Fillion almost
immediately my immediate supervisor
legendary Dr philion
why we didn't at least have subpoena
Powers while other investigators
overseeing licensure had that tool over
at oplc I didn't get a reasonable answer
and I'd been asking ever since for 10
years
I think it's very important to
understand very definitively that my
first and most important mission is to
keep Kids Safe
I have been called to public service for
nearly 40 years and I take this
responsibility very very seriously this
is about kid keeping kids in our school
safe and protecting them from the one
percent of Educators who do not share in
this belief
that's right one percent
I work for commissioner Barry I now work
for commissioner edelblue and God
willing I will work for another
commissioner in the future this is not
as a local newspaper to trumpeted this
past Sunday edelblood seeks subpoena
power to investigate educated misconduct
that's not what this is about
I am asking the agency is asking and we
need to do three things this request has
nothing to do with political agenda on
me carrying water for any commissioner
I need these tools to complete my
mission
the three-prong mission is protect our
most vulnerable neighbors our children
protect our educators
that's right well over ninety percent of
our cases alleging misconduct are deemed
to be unfounded we exonerate more
teachers every day than we do
take action against the license of a
teacher
over the past 10 years I've been
investigated on average 150 cases that
we log in as cases to meet our triage
process
in any given year we take action
suspensions or revocations involving
10 Educators on average
this does not count the many reports we
get that do not survive our triage
process and finally the third part of
our mission is to remove
Educators that did damaging our kids
over the past 10 years I've been faced
with difficult tasks of asking for
information many times I've been dying
access to reports statements witness
information names ages local
disciplinary records investigative
findings and other crucial bits of
evidence that would have assisted in
protecting students exonerating
Educators falsely accused and removing
bad apples from our classrooms I'm sorry
did you say you said you had been denied
access is that what you're saying that's
correct
over the past two to three years school
districts are routinely hiring
third-party investigators attorneys that
work for the districts as contractors
and in fact a new company has been
started that focuses strictly on
providing third-party investigations for
school districts most of the time we are
not allowed to look at those reports we
don't have subpoena power to get those
reports sometimes we're allowed to
review them in camera in in a conference
room at a law firm and glean the
information from those many times we're
not allowed to touch them at all many of
our most difficult and heinous cases
involving the exploitation of our
children the sexual exploitation of our
children began on social media postings
text messaging and the use of cell
phones
often the initial triage of these cases
do not appear to be criminal in nature
therefore are many many partners in law
enforcement could not assist us in
getting the information that we needed
we have no tools to get this information
because we have no subpoena Powers again
the kids are left hanging the teachers
accused have no support and don't have
the information to regenerate them and
the bad teacher has the possibility of
slipping off the hook again this comes
down to relationships I've created and
creativity in the investigations
we have all have been very lucky that
this agency and I and school districts
and their staff Union reps and their
attorneys work reasonably well together
to get the job done but the day is
coming when this will not happen
I amazed I'm amazed absolutely amazed
that an investigator for oplc can
subpoena records associated with Barbers
cosmeticians nurses and other licensees
and the Department of Education will
oversee the safety of children do not
have that Authority
it's 2023
our children should be protected and
subpoena power will allow us to do that
thank you very much if you have any
questions questions for this for either
of these Witnesses
yes representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question will this
cover
all School Employees for example will it
cover the uh the principles the
custodians
um or is it just Educators so for for my
purposes as educated misconduct it's for
license holders so that would be
superintendents assistant
superintendents principals
administrators teachers
paraprofessionals that hold licenses
all right other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you oh I'm sorry
representative Brennan
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um earlier in your testimony you stated
that one percent of teachers do not
share the common goal of keeping our
children safe and I'm wondering if you
might be able to provide the source for
that number I'd be happy to give you the
the list of suspended revoked Educators
that we've compiled
um we can do it by uh year we can do it
by alphabetical order but it's a small
percentage of people that have engaged
in misconduct that have put Children at
Risk and that's the one percent I'm
talking about follow-up please yeah
to New Hampshire Educators or is that a
nationwide figure that'd be New
Hampshire I don't have any
facts or figures to support any other
state but the one that I work in
thank you
Lorenzo take a mistake here
sir could you tell me what the
significance of your Irish heritage has
to do with this bill oh it's a a kind of
like a little bit of Blarney that I have
it's nice to be able to communicate with
uh
create relationships get people to trust
that I'm not working opposed to their
position
um it's it's
um
sometimes it's either easier to convince
people to be on your team than trying to
pound them over the head thank you
representative page yeah thanks for
taking my question top of the morning
um
so the just I want to have a question in
terms of what you defined you said the
license holders would come under the
purview of this subpoena power right so
if I have a license to teach or
administrate or whatever a neighbor does
that the department would have that
authority over that person
wherever they may be
and I'm gonna assist on this question I
just could he answer that question
though I I think he he mentioned that I
want to understand he's doing the
investigation that's why he's here right
he certainly is yeah
so
the code of conduct is the method that
we uh that we use to conduct
investigations and the code of conduct
is very limited in its scope and the
scope is a license holder so for example
we cannot go in and examine a custodian
a kitchen staffer a secretary because
they don't hold licenses with the
Department of Education so my
investigations in the code of conduct is
limited to those persons who hold
licenses that we control anybody else in
the school district
any other employee we can't use the
subpoena power for them because they're
not licensed holders so it's limited to
those persons that hold the license
another question follow-up sure yeah
changing subjects quickly it sounded
like if I understood your testimony
correctly
you said that you're having success
in your job right now but the day will
come
is that what you said we're having
success
um and
we are getting increasingly pushed back
from
certain stakeholders that are saying no
we're not going to provide that
information for you I can give you
anecdotal or I can give you definitive
information that for example just this
week we had a an educator that has come
under our radar as licensed educator
that was that uh is under investigation
and I had to deal with three different
superintendents to ask for assistance in
an investigation to to determine whether
or not misconduct may have occurred I
got three different answers from three
different superintendents two of which
were great and very assisting one flat
out said no I'm not going to give you
that information
and it's crucial information to
determine whether or not educated
misconduct occurred and any action that
we might take regarding this educator so
I had one case three superintendents one
flat out said no thank you I don't have
any authority to say to the
superintendent no I really need this
information please please please give me
this information I don't have the
authority to do it so I have three
superintendents
two had levels of cooperation one said
no
other questions yes representative
Greece thank you Mr chair and thank you
sir for answering our questions
is a subpoena a first line of action or
a last line of action for you for me
it'd be the last line of action I would
exhaust every other opportunity I had
and that would be the last thing that I
would use
other questions for this witness
representative Manos
thank you Mr Turk
um I believe you talked about third
party investigators and those are
contractors with the Department of
Education no contractors for school
districts
okay
and so you're having difficulty getting
their reports correct
thank you
representative Andrews
thank you Mr chant thank you for taking
my question and either one of you can
answer this if this only deals with
licensed
employees of a school district
who where does it fall other employees
if they are come under misconduct who do
they
complained to it would be an employment
issue that the district would address
other questions representative Smith
yes
thank you following up on my colleagues
question
um uh in that situation if you were
aware of a problem uh would you uh it's
someone who's not licensed but employed
in the public schools in this state
would you be able to go to the Attorney
General's office with attorney general
providing counsel for all agencies to
ask for help in in getting
um
that information whether it requires a
subpoena or not when it comes to
non-licensed persons I routinely have
referred those type of cases to the
local County attorney the local police
and other partners that we have because
sometimes that Behavior Uh that is in
question may be border on criminal
Behavior so we would immediately I
immediately pass that on to other
authorities we just had I think you
probably saw the news that a bus driver
was arrested yesterday we got that
information from the school district
from the superintendent almost within
minutes after he became aware of it we
immediately I immediately forwarded to
the chief of police and the Hudson
police department and they conducted a
robust investigation that had had
nothing to do with us but we were able
to refer it to the right agency
other questions for this witness yes
representative
um thank you for taking my question
um so you just
met an educator was found
um or you're looking into investigating
and why would you have more than one
superintendent to
um ask the you know to question about
that person don't you normally just have
one superintendent that the educator
would be under
in this particular case and and very
often this is the case this involved
three superintendents one was
superintendent of a district at the time
the person was initially hired the
second superintendent was the new
superintendent
who works in that same district and the
third superintendent was a previous
employer so we went out and asked each
one of those superintendents to assist
us in triaging that case
representative Horrigan
thank you very much you mentioned the
case of the bus driver and I read about
that in the newspaper I guess it was
this morning or yesterday morning they
all kind of meld together
and actually the case of the bus driver
bus drivers are licensed but I think
they're to drive
school buses but they're licensed by the
dot but um and
this is a little bit out of the purview
of ours so is there a question yes it's
going to be yes a little bit of the
purview a question and we're going
against the political Trend does anybody
listen to Governor's budget address
knows but would it make your job easier
for a house we licensed um
everybody who was in a child facing role
with the schools regardless of whether
or not they were Educators or
paraprofessionals or just support staff
well
it you know the answer is no it wouldn't
make my job easier and I think we have
to Define who educators are and what the
code of conduct is so I think by
expanding I wouldn't want to expand the
role of this agency to be involved with
persons that are not licensed
yes
good morning good morning I'm in a
different place right
no chair
um good morning and thank you for taking
my question
um I think you testified that
um you said without the subpoena power
you would have no authority to get the
information that you were requesting so
what is the scope of the subpoena is it
you can get any information you want I
mean what's the hook for you know
containing what information your
subpoena power has the subpoena power
would be limited to what I asked for uh
so I wouldn't it it's not a phishing
that that would go out and you know drag
the ocean for all types of information
it'd be specific a report for example uh
Personnel record for example uh past
disciplinary practices or actions
against the educator those are the type
of things witness statements uh we're
not casting a wide net and trying to
capture people in that net we want to be
very limited and focused on the
allegation and those things associated
with the allegation
yes so I think that's what I'm asking so
you're not limited within the scope of
whatever you want absolutely not and and
keep in mind
code of conduct is my guide that that's
the my boundaries those just like uh
when I was in the State Police there are
certain things those um I have to stay
within my lane and the code of conduct
is my lane and I don't go outside that
code of conduct I don't go outside those
Lanes so the idea that
you'll see if you look at
the code of conduct you have to be very
careful
that people weaponize the code of
conduct parents weaponize it on occasion
school districts perhaps
um
we don't want to weaponize the code we
want to stay within the bounds of the
code and weaponizing it is really a bad
idea
thank you other questions for this
witness yes Representatives excuse me
sir
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
the question
um I I'm sort of going back to the idea
this is a um an amendment to the
original bill that came before us
um and I know it's a full replacement of
that bill
um but I guess my question is the
original bill
um basically and I believe that's why
it's before this committee um
this uh specifically targeted complaints
um related to student discriminary
discriminatory practices
um and I'm wondering
is the request before us now sounds like
it may be much broader than sort of
things related to student discriminary
discriminatory practices so I'm
wondering how you see the the split
between the two and whether or not this
is actually much broader than than sort
of what originally was put before us
thanks
different concept and the the original
House Bill 533
um and as I mentioned at the beginning
of my testimony
um Richard Farrell had been asking for
this type of Bill uh for for quite a
while and in working with representative
Lynn and working with the Attorney
General's office on the original House
Bill 533
um we have since worked with the AG's
office to come up with a an sop as to
how we transfer those cases to the Human
Rights Commission and the AG's office it
was brought up in that conversation kind
of separate and apart from it that the
department should probably seek subpoena
power for the code of conduct
investigations that we do and so we
thought that this would be the
opportunity to to do that and my
understanding is representative Lynn has
worked or spoken to the Attorney
General's office about this amendment
but obviously I will let him speak to
that no that no that's true the the
second the um
the amendment uh 2023
-0739h is slight you'll see that the
wording of that is slightly different
than the earlier proposed amendment and
that change in wording reflects
Suggestions by the Attorney General's
office that's that's why the that's the
slight slight change in wording okay so
just quick follow-up so and I don't know
whether I'm asking this of uh um the uh
the scope then of what we're talking
about today
um would go beyond sort of the the
original bill in terms of of not just
targeting discriminatory complaints but
targeting essentially any issue before
the
um that that comes before you
eat the short answer to your question is
yes it is broader but I'm going to it's
a Nuance because it falls directly
within the code of conduct so to
reference back to Richard Farrell we are
within the bounds of the code of conduct
but it is outside
um of the discriminatory practices yes
other questions for the yes
representative Payne about Paige I'm
sorry that could be true
um so I'm just trying an off uh bouncing
a little bit off of Representative
tourist question on the timeline and I'm
trying to catch up from the original
Bill to the Amendments we have with the
subpoena issue here before us but if I'm
understanding this correctly
Mr Farrell's been working at the
Department of Education for about 10
years
2018 is when the code of conduct has was
passed or adopted however we want to
phrase that
and now it's 2023 but Mr Farrell's been
asking for The subpoena power for as
long as he's been employed there
is this the first time the Department's
asked this is a yes or no is this the
first time the Department's asked for
subpoena power yes
other other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
um next I'm going to call on uh Barrett
Christina
good morning uh chairman Lynn good
morning members of the committee Barrett
Christina from the New Hampshire school
boards Association as we were opposed
with the original Bill were opposed to
the amendment as well too I'm going to
get as many words in as I can in two
minutes
um as the conversation just went nhsba
would argue that um this amendment is
not germane to the original Bill the
first bill dealt with the um human
rights complaints um the Department of
Education this one is a completely
different topic under the teacher code
of conduct completely different statute
we don't think it's Germaine
um second according to the Department of
Education website 12 Educators have lost
their license in 2022 nine in 2021 the
system seems to be working while it may
not always be easy the process is
working and we're getting bad teachers
out of out of the buildings and taking
their licenses
um third and perhaps most importantly
NHS believe
um believes that this um has the
potential to be an infringement on
parental rights
um as the as the the proposed amendment
says any person can be subpoenaed there
are no guard rails for children
um in the bill with the subpoena power
um does the department have to notify
parents um if a student is going to be
or if a child is going to be subpoenaed
and hypothetically if I were a parent
and I got a subpoena from the Department
of Education I'd probably tell them to
pound sand
um before I just let my kid be subject
to to to to to some sort of
Investigation again no guard rails for
for students the other aspect too that
we need to be mindful of there was a lot
of talk about student safety relative to
the code of conduct the teacher code of
conduct and while that's absolutely
Paramount
um the the code of conduct is much
broader
um than than just student safety there
things personal behaviors that could be
done on a weekend that have no bearing
on children that could be a violation of
the code of conduct so is this relative
to student safety and obviously to some
degree but the broader aspect is that
it's part of of the the teacher code of
conduct so um those I think are the
primary aspects nhsba has for opposing
for opposing this particular Amendment
and I'm happy to answer any questions
and I hope I've got it under my two
minutes question you I think you have
questions for this witness
representative Smith
uh thank you very much
um miss defense said something that
shocked me uh and he said that about one
percent
of the uh the people I don't want to say
teachers the people covered lie the
licensed professionals
um are
again I'll use the word suspect that's
not a I'm not a lawyer so it's not the
legal term and that shocked me one
percent to me sounds very very high do
you have any indication
based on the information that you have
access to that one out of every 100
Professionals in the New Hampshire
education system it should be removed
thank you for the question uh
representative I don't have any
particular data relative to that
thank you other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next going to call on Megan Tuttle
okay
good morning Mr chairman members of the
host Judiciary Committee for the record
my name is Megan Tuttle president of Nea
New Hampshire we represent over 17 000
New Hampshire Educators in our K-12
public schools and in higher education
I'm here today and to testify an
opposition to the non-germain amendment
to House Bill 533
the amendment before you we feel is
unnecessary and unwarranted we're not
aware of any material the doe has asked
for in the course of an investigation
under the code of conduct that they have
not received so asking for this added
power is important for them to concrete
in asking for this power it's important
for them to concretely articulate why it
is they need this new ability to date we
haven't heard this Justified we're
hoping to hear more justification about
it today
we feel the legislature should be
cautious on why agencies Beyond law
enforcement should hold such power if
the department at some point needs to
issue a subpoena there's no reason they
cannot go to the Department of Justice
if truly if they truly needed access to
some sort of material the department
always has access to 91a at its disposal
which is very Broad in its application
for public documents
my second point is we're very concerned
that this amendment would apply to the
preliminary stage of an investigation
rather than when a formal
oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry yes and I had two minutes I I
will slow down I apologize
so my second point is we're very
concerned that this amendment would
apply to the preliminary stage of an
investigation rather than when a formal
complaint is launched under RSA 354a
which operationally has been conducted
by the Human Rights Commission or the
Department of Justice the ability to
have subpoena power this early in a
process does have us concerned that this
tool would be used for phishing
Expedition for the band Concepts issues
as recent as this Sunday on close-up
when asked whether the doe should have
subpoena power Ryan Terrell the State
Board of Education member cited reasons
of curriculum concerns as to why this is
needed that gives us added concern as
the motivation for asking for such a
power
this is yet another reason to require
the doe to ask the doj for subpoena if
they should need it
we're really wondering is this really
just for children's safety or any
concern that somebody has against an
educator
who would be the decision maker of when
a subpoena is necessary
you may have heard that this is similar
language afforded which we did here to
the office of professional licensure and
so why not have it for the doe as well
we don't believe the two agencies are
similar bodies simply because they both
supervise licenses
the Department of Education handles and
has laws that apply to it that are far
different more public and frankly more
political than the boards under that
umbrella agency
the doe has a commissioner who is a
political appointee and of the governor
and the qualification for the State
Board of Education members do not
require as many of the oplc boards do
that its members be Educators within the
profession
thank you for your time I know this was
quick
um and hearing our opposition to the
legislation
questions for this witness or either of
these Witnesses
yeah uh yes representative Macbeth thank
you
um thank you for your testimony I was
interested in the different in the board
the licensing board uh do any of the
license board have a code of conduct for
their licensing do you know that's as
broad as what teachers would be under a
license under the Department of
Education
thank you for the question I do not know
of any
um Brian Hawkins might
sure and I'll fill out a pin card Mr
chairman I didn't have one originally
um yes I'm sorry can you order can you
just identify yourself for the record
Ryan Hawkins I think you're with uh
president Tuttle
um uh I am only familiar with the the
code the code of conduct under the
Department of Education there there are
certainly guidelines under uh those
other boards uh but I wouldn't
be able to cite what all of those are
all right other questions for this
Witness
yes representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
you said that you were concerned that
these subpoenas might be used for a
fishing Expedition for banned Concepts
if something is prohibited from being
taught and yet a teacher teaches it is
that not then a violation of the code of
conduct and therefore worthy of an
investigation
sure so so uh currently on under the
band concept A lot of the operational
procedure for uh a a a in when a
complaint is filed that is under the uh
the under the Human Rights Commission so
it it is not under the Department of
Education Department of Education only
comes in with the licensure when the
Human Rights Commission has determined
it to be a violation of 354a
yes but that's operationally
representative Brenner thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um the two previous people who have
testified were unable to provide us with
some figures regarding this claim of one
percent of Educators not sharing the
common goal of the safety of our
children and I'm wondering if you might
be able to provide us with some
information about how many Educators
there are in New Hampshire and perhaps
what that one percent figure might look
like
anyway
well I I there there were some numbers
that uh Mr Christina who preceded us uh
referenced with respect to uh licensure
uh uh revocation and
um
and suspensions
um uh not today I wouldn't be able to uh
but you know one thing I think
um in the last uh 48 Hours we've had a
series of bills uh that have centered
around education and educators
and it is uh one of the things we've
talked we talked about frequently across
the hall with uh chairman Ladd and the
education committee there is you know we
have a uh we have a shortage of
Educators in this state and in the last
uh 48 Hours we've had bills that have to
that uh present uh criminal penalties
um being litigated against individually
over in the Senate and now a subpoena
power bill and um so maybe not specific
to this amendment but it is a broad
concern the message that we're sending
uh with some of these pieces of
legislation because as as has been noted
uh by both the department and uh the
previous uh testimony
uh the vast oh
so many of our Educators their number
one concern are their students and their
children
um Megan is a as an is is an actual
educator so I can I'll for her defer to
her on that but so it is distressing to
hear uh particularly in light of the
legislation that we've been hearing over
the last couple of days
quick follow-up if I may yes if that's
okay
I'm I want to make sure that I
understand this amendment correctly and
what the real world impact of something
like this would be and given the
shortage of teachers and
um the lack of pipeline you know that
New Hampshire in particular but of
course across the country
um for new teachers there are less who
will maybe less college students who may
be pursuing education as a career and
I'm wondering if it would be your
testimony that something like this would
provide a chilling effect
um for you know possible new Educators
or Educators who are currently serving
our students
um there would it be a chilling effect
for their willingness to continue
serving our children
thank you for the question
um yes I I do actually think it would
have that exact effect we do have a
shortage of the pipeline as you
mentioned coming in we don't have a lot
of high school kids that are going into
the profession of teaching the number of
students in the pre-service college
classes and colleges is shrinking
um and so adding this on top of you know
five years to get what's commonly
referred to as tenure in New Hampshire
which is more than any of our
surrounding states adding it to the low
pay the teachers are getting in New
Hampshire adding it to everything that
Mr Hawkins was just talking about with
bills being heard things that have been
passed in the year in the past year or
so this is definitely going to add I
think a chilling effect and not really
attract Educators to New Hampshire
for your prior question I could answer a
little piece of that with numbers and I
am an 18-year social studies teacher of
eighth grade so I was in the classroom
for a long time I'm a parent I have kids
of my own so all this is personal as
well as you know professional for me
um we represent 17 000 Educators and
when we talk about Educators that
includes everything from teachers to
paraprofessionals to
um non-licensed bus drivers Food Service
workers Etc of those 17 000 about 14 000
or so give or take are actual teachers
in front of a classroom we also
represent like I said the ESP in New
Hampshire aft also represents teachers
and districts that we don't represent so
they have added numbers I think the last
figure that I heard was about 26 or 27
000 actual teachers in New Hampshire I
could be off on that so please don't
quote me but it's around that number
give or take that does not include
paraprofessionals that might have
licenses and and that sort of thing so
if it helps to put a little bit of the
number together I hope that helps father
just on those numbers if I may please
yes thank you so much I really
appreciate it
if we're talking about up to 27 000
teachers in the state of New Hampshire
one percent seems like a very large
number of teachers who would have
pursued
um as you said the five-year education
plan to get 10-year
um
I'm trying to wrap my mind around this
idea of one percent
um of 27 000 teachers who may not share
this common goal of safety for our
children and does that number does that
one percent number ring true to you
thank you for the question I was a
little shocked by it I'm not sure that
does seem high to be honest
other questions yes representative page
thanks for taking my question
um
I know in the federal rules of civil
procedure The subpoena power is granted
when there's uh and then there has to be
a docket number attached I think it's
even listed under the trial sort of
procedure part this this proposal here
seems to suggest that um
subpoena could be issued at any point in
an investigation whenever that occurs
and I know in New Hampshire sometimes we
do things and we're leaders and
sometimes maybe we're not and I'm
wondering comparatively
are we outliers in suggesting that we
should have the subpoena power in so in
in the beginning or at any point in the
process when we compare ourselves to
other states is that making where are we
outliers in this in this proposal
uh I I in in in in in a quick sort of
pull of my of some colleagues around the
state I didn't get any similar uh
uh equivalence uh that that to this
proposal that were first sent to me so I
I apologize if that's somewhat anecdotal
and not more concrete uh with a little
bit more time between a public hearing
the the hearing today and I we just saw
the the latest Amendment and the
executive session at 10 o'clock
um could probably get you something more
complete but
um I don't know if you did you want to
edit other questions for this
representative Horrigan
thank you very much is it
I was listening to the hearings uh
yesterday on YouTube and uh well we're
not talking about any of those bills but
is there anything the code of conducted
uh says it's a violation for Teacher to
merely you know be
openly gay or trans or lgbtq in some way
is that no I guess I'm I'm wondering how
is that germane to the issue that's
before us now well it's just part of the
general political climate that's being
introduced in but um so yeah so yeah you
may answer the question if you can I
think they did yeah
no no
all right any other questions for this
Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you both very much
Mr chairman oh yes thank thank you Mr uh
uh Jill's missing that please
thank you
good morning good morning your honor Mr
chairman members of the committee thank
you so much for the opportunity to
testify today and I'll I'll try to be
brief I know I only have uh two minutes
uh we uh again for the record geopacinet
legal director at the ACLU of New
Hampshire we are opposed to the
amendment
um and want to just flush out three or
four reasons why but just at the the
outset you know I know part of the
rationalization or justification I
should say for this bill has been
obviously the need to protect child
safety I think we can all can all can
agree how critical and important that is
I'm a Concord resident well aware of
what happened in Concord
um several several years ago but I do
want to be clear that this this bill is
not limited to child safety right it it
it doesn't have that type of limitation
embedded within it and would allow
subpoena power
um for the entire scope of the educator
code of conduct which goes you know far
beyond uh oftentimes child safety so if
you want this to be about child safety I
mean my recommendation would be making
about child safety narrow it and tailor
it uh to that because the educator code
of conduct and if anyone kind of goes
through it you'll you'll kind of see
that it's
um not too dissimilar from other kind of
professional codes but it is very broad
right you know you can be deemed to a
violated educative code of conduct for
unprofessional conduct and the code goes
on to say including but not limited to
so it is expansive in that sense but I
just want to flag that for the committee
and I know also as well uh you know part
of the justification for this amendment
has been well this is really a different
concept The subpoena power is
fundamentally different from the origins
of the original bill I do want to say
that they are very related though
um because this amendment would give the
Department of Education subpoena power
to enforce the band Concepts action
divisive concept act or the law against
discrimination too whatever you do
however you want to describe it right it
would allow for
um subpoena power to enforce that
statute and I think this is problematic
given what we believe to be ambiguities
in that act in full disclosure we have a
pending lawsuit challenging that
particular statute and one of the
concerns and that we have raised in
court about that statute is that the ACT
gives multiple agencies through power to
enforce it which could lead to arbitrary
and just discriminatory decision making
when you have both the Department of
Education Department of Justice the
Human Rights Commission the Department
of Labor and the New Hampshire courts
all involved in that degree of info of
enforcement and what this would really
do in expanding the does
uh enforcement power over that law by
virtue of subpoena power I only think it
would continue that Prospect of leading
to the potential for arbitrary
indiscriminatory enforcement so that is
to say there's a fragmented enforcement
scheme already with the band Concepts
law and I think this would really just
expand that and potentially even render
that act even more unconstitutional than
we think it already is
relatedly the second point I would just
like to make is that the amendment would
give the Department of Education
subpoena power over certain portions of
the educator code of conduct where the
Department of Justice and Human Rights
Commission already have subpoena in
investigatory powers and that's not only
in the context of the banned Concepts
Act
but also uh in with respect to the law
against discrimination RSA 354 a so um I
just wanted to flag that that it's
really important to know that there are
already agencies that have enforcement
authority over that they already have
subpoena authority over that and I think
with respect to those Provisions it's
really unclear to me why subpoena power
in the hands of the doe would be
particularly necessary
the last point I do want to make is that
the amendment really does contain no
criteria for when a subpoena can be
issued as written the amendment allows
Department of Education to issue a
subpoena even the absence of a formal
written complaint
um we don't think that the absence of
such criteria before the issuance of a
subpoena would be appropriate we think
that's an important limitation in
addition the amendment also allows
Department to issue a subpoena in the
absence of an investigation formerly
being opened where the department has
initially determined that a possible
violation of the code of conduct has
occurred and I think we think that is an
important limitation as well and I I
would also suggest and I'm not an expert
on the oplc regime and how they operate
but when you look at the entirety of the
oplc statute that I believe this is
modeled after and it's RSA
310-a colon 1-j
um
uh and I would maybe ask oplc to confirm
this whether they agree disagree but it
seems to me that a subpoena potentially
only could be issued after an
investigation has formally been
conducted and I think that's an
important limitation if my reading of
that statute is correct but that
limitation doesn't exist um in the
amendment so I think if if this is a
path that the committee wants to go down
and again we have concerns for the
reasons that I just previously stated I
think these limitations are very
important and it was referenced before
in the litigation context you can't
issue a subpoena until a lawsuit has
been filed and Discovery has been
allowed to proceed which would occur
usually after emotion if emotion
dismisses filed after that motion to
dismiss
um is is denied so important limitation
that exists in litigation context but
again those types of limitations are not
necessarily spelled out here and the
last thing I would note and I know that
the Department of Education
investigators said that you know he
um
he would use the subpoena power as the
last line and I no reason to dispute
that at all but I've been kind of doing
this job long enough
to know when you have broad provisions
of power without limitations it could
create issues down the line so I would
just suggest that the committee um
think through those uh possibilities in
the in the law against discrimination
context where the Department of Justice
actually has subpoena Authority it seems
that it can only do so after again the
filing of a formal complaint so that
limitation exists there and I would
suggest that such limitations should be
considered by the committee and with
that I'll conclude my testimony I'm sure
I went over two minutes I'm sorry I'm
sorry questions for this Witness I have
one yes representative Perez thank you I
have one question does the American
civil liberties Union
also speak for children
and parents at any time
I think we we do our best when civil
liberties and civil rights are
implicated no matter who's impacted
whether it's children parents other
groups to to try to address those
concerns on behalf of those
constituencies
options for this witness seeing none
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman thank you
um uh David Trumbull please
hi strumble hello thank you Mr chairman
I'm David Trumbull I'm from the town
aware representing myself I'm opposed to
this bill for several reasons first is I
think the use of the Attorney General is
a more appropriate means for this to be
enacted looking up other places where
children are at stake look at RSA 170
e41 deals with daycare residential
centers and child placement agencies the
commissioner of HHS then can get a
subpoena by going to the attorney
general and showing good cause so if
this is only being used as a last resort
as the investigator testified just do it
that way that's an example that works
number two is the analogy to the oplc
really doesn't work and here's why under
RSA 310a they lay out a whole series of
procedural due process requirements that
are absent from the bill in front of you
first a complaint has to be filed in
under the oplc not here sir service to
the person who the complaint is against
has to be given not here the oplc
requires long record keeping so that
they can keep track of their subpoena
systems nothing here for the doe to do
that lastly there's an oversight
Committee in the legislature to oversee
the oplc nothing in this bill says that
the doe has to then come back and
provide you with data so you can make
sure that it's being done properly
number three if as testified this bill
has nothing to do with divisive Concepts
then write that into the law that this
bill does not apply to cases that are
going to the Human Rights Commission
that would avoid the problem that the
attorney from the issue you said where
you have multiple disparate agencies
running through this issue number four
the oplc is an oversight agency go to
their website and on the about who are
we section it says they provide
administrative clerical business
processing and record keeping support to
like 47 different occupational groups
they only actually oversee a couple of
the smaller ones they're not doing
independent investigations this bill
creates unchecked power for the
Department of Education at any stage to
go issue subpoenas and do it on their
own that's different than the oplc so if
you're using that as a model I suggest
you do some research on the oplc lastly
this is a broader question of
administrative investigations I'll
finish with a short sentence from
Professor gavor who teaches law at
George Washington law school he wrote an
article in 2020. on this topic he said
another harm from improper agency
investigations is constitutional
horizontal separation of powers concerns
many administrative agencies operate in
a zone that is free of oversight from
both the policy prerogatives of the
first branch and the oversight of the
third branch especially if the organic
statute provides no guidelines or review
of investigative practices the result
the totally and systematically is the
risk of tyrannical Behavior by agencies
and within them bureaucrats who are not
politically accountable this bill gives
broad power it does not set up any
checks on that power it's a risk no
matter what political party you're from
you don't want to create that much power
without risk put some guidelines on this
go through the Attorney General that's
what we do with daycare residential
centers that would be a more reasonable
step thank you questions for this
witness yes representative lorenza Take
Care thank you for your testimony do you
have written copies of um what you um I
don't have anything I can send something
to the committee tonight
thank you so much thank you for the
questions
yes representative Macbeth thank you so
thank you for your testimony and again
this might you might not be the right
person but I'm interested in this broad
um you know the code of conducts the the
Department of Education has is there
anything like that I mean that you found
that the uh oplc would be um
investigating as far as you know code of
contact the oplc has it's kind of an
oversight Agency for
um of the types of groups they deal with
is from body artists to
um septic system groups to Health
Providers at 47 different types of
agencies who all individually seem to
govern their own profession with a
couple of small exceptions apparently
only three or four
they all obviously have strong codes
that they have to follow I think the
difference is that those types of
professions and the what's going on with
the oplc is they're looking at technical
competence like did you actually measure
the septic system properly or is the
tattoo artist being safe in their
workplace this bill has the potential to
be used not just for technical
compliance but for content in other
words the commissioner could or a future
commissioner could or the person who's
now on the State Board of Education
could become a future commissioner and
use this bill to govern content in the
classroom so they could say well you you
started talking about race issues in in
the class and I don't want you doing
that so the chilling effect the
potential chilling effect on our
teachers could be that they'll just say
I don't want to get subpoenaed just
because I brought up a civil rights
issue in my class so they stop talking
about these important things
you're welcome other other questions for
this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you
uh Mary uh Wilkie please
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Mary Wilke I'm from
Concord I'm a retired public school
teacher and could you speak closer to
the microphone sure do you mean me to
repeat that
okay thank you
um I oppose HB 533 as amended and I um
for many of the reasons that have
already been stated I want to just add
that I think it's really important to
consider this bill in the context of
what's been going on in the last few
years regarding public education
as a retired teacher I've found it
incredibly disheartening to see Bill
after Bill filed in this legislature
based on the premise that teachers spend
their days indoctrinating children
wanting them to become marxists wanting
them to feel guilty about their skin
color sharing obscene materials with
them or pushing them to change their
gender identities
in all of the schools I've taught in or
volunteered in over the course of my
life or that my own children and
grandchildren have attended I've never
met a single teacher that fits that
description
if teachers are lying awake at night
it's not trying to dream up ways to
indoctrinate their students it's
worrying about how that reluctant reader
and how to spark an interest in reading
or worrying about that child whose
mother is dying of cancer how to support
that child
passing meanwhile
um
the Department of Education has a portal
on its website encouraging parents to
report so-called Rogue teachers and the
moms of Liberty put out a 500 bounty on
the hands of teachers and you'd get 500
if you reported a teacher and they got
prosecuted under the divisive Concepts
bill
it's just so painful this this constant
unfounded attack on public schools some
of which is being funded by national
groups that are trying to undermine the
whole concept of public education
um
I guess I I just want to say that if you
pass a bill like this now in this
environment it just piles on to those
accusations it sends the message that
teachers need to be subpoenaed that they
are harboring suspect documents that
have to be seized because we just can't
trust Public Public School teachers and
I just hope that you will consider that
as collateral damage of passing a bill
like this in this time thank you thank
you questions for this Witness
yes representative Brennan thank you
thank you for taking my question
would it be fair to say or would it be
fair to
um
interpret your testimony
would it be an accurate interpretation
of your testimony to suggest that the
amendment that's before this committee
today
isn't is based on political reasoning
rather than something based in data in
fact is that an accurate interpretation
of your no I don't know I'm not quite
sure of the relevance of that to
anything we have but go ahead I'm I'm I
tend to let people
it's up to you you may answer or not
answer it's up to you
I don't know what the motive
motivate context is and and right now
there's
seems to be constant
um innuendo through often through
legislation or through attempts at
legislation innuendo that casts
dispersions on public school teachers
that I think are unfounded
other questions for this witness thank
you that that helps thank you
thank you very none thank you very much
thank you
um Deborah Howes please
foreign
okay
uh
yeah thank you chairman Lynn and members
of the Judiciary Committee uh I'm here
to speak against this amendment to HB
533 I'm Deborah house president of the
American Federation of teachers we've
got about 4 000 members across the
straight state in pre-k through 12
education
um
you know teachers all sorts of Educators
um School support staff as well as in
the University system and in various
Town employees so much of what I've said
has already been covered by President
tunnel from Nea and by the New Hampshire
ACLU so I'll stick to a few points here
we do feel that this subpoena power
despite you know what we heard and we we
believe the good intentions of the
investigator but we feel the um
Amendment would be overly broad it would
give an unprecedented power to a
political appointee to allow for
subpoenas at any time during an
investigation without appropriate guard
rails to protect the rights of someone
who is just
accused without maybe even knowing
they're being accused
until that Sabina arrives
you know there's nothing in that
amendment that says when those subpoenas
would come and I I do believe the good
intentions of that limited list that we
heard about but it's not in writing so
therefore that doesn't necessarily mean
it would occur past the time when that
gentleman is holding that position
um
and I want to talk a little bit about
the code of conduct that covers all of
your licensed Professionals in schools
teachers guidance counselors
um you know school principals all of
them but it covers every interaction you
have with the student so it's not a
narrow scope we're talking about it's
everything you do that involves students
it's very broad so you could be
subpoenaed about any interaction you
have with the student at any time that
happens now or in the past that's a lot
of ground you could cover with it
um
and if this is about safety of students
you are missing all of those people who
work in schools
that do not have a license so it is not
answering the problem necessarily it is
just
going after one portion of the
population that works in schools
we heard from the presenters of this
amendment that the code of conduct has
been weaponized and we have seen that
and we are feeling that my members are
feeling that we hear allegations you you
know have heard mention of some of them
in this room about how teachers are
being accused of teaching
all sorts of
things that uh is news to us that we're
teaching them okay we we are not out
there you know teaching
children they can choose their gender or
things all sorts of other
really
astounding allegations
but that's the weaponization that we
fear
would turn into
code of conduct investigations and
subpoenas if this amendment were to be
passed so it would lead to more
harassment of your certified
professionals and a greater flight from
your education system
increasing the workforce shortage
so the limitations are not written into
the bill
it's overly Broad and it's going to
drive people out of the profession when
really what we want to do is have the
ability to focus on educating our
students and giving them what they need
to learn and succeed that's what we're
asking for we're asking for Less
interference
in doing our jobs we're not asking for
any sort of you know
lessening of the safety aspects but
don't put
an inappropriate
the broad tool in someone's hands that
could be misused however no matter whose
hand it's it it could be misused it has
great potential for becoming a weapon
against a whole lot of people who are
just trying to help students questions
thank you questions for this Witness
yes uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I think we heard earlier that there was
Specter of false allegations made
against teachers
that's a very harmful thing
is there a possibility that the supine
of power
not only is accusatory but exculpatory
and can actually get to the truth and
um relieve those teachers of the Specter
of false accusation
that's not a question that I have any
information to answer so I will not
attempt it I
yeah
I
I can't give you anything to shed light
on that I I apologize but no that's
that's all right it was a point of
thought it is a point of thought but um
I I can't get you any further along the
line there
other questions for this witness thank
you very much okay
I see I have no other uh Pink cards from
anyone is there anyone else who wishes
to testify on the amendment to HB 533
seeing none I'm gonna close the hearing
on HB 533
um
all right so what I'm going to do is
we're we're going to uh
um I'm going to open and immediately
recess the executive session we're going
to take about a 15 minute break because
I'm I'm myself and representative kutab
are for lack of a better term using a
point of personal privilege the band the
school band from Windham is playing over
it before the executive Council and we
want to go over and at least make a
brief appearance before just to support
them
no
that's that would definitely be a turn
off let me tell you for sure
other modifications
I'm trying
to understand
what's your
name
like this
upstairs
and now you're going to be doubting
myself
foreign
two
that's right
okay
foreign
-674
but
okay
yeah yeah
hi uh the chair told me that neither of
them or answered
foods to consult you know I don't know
how that happened which is much like new
about it
um we're about to start the exact
section so we saw that
let's break
the amendment each Amendment
I mean you know
it's it's relationship
oh okay
um
she has to stop
open up
okay yeah yeah
you were great
because she is
excuse me yeah
yourself
let me just because
what shouldn't be not fair
um
a few hours
I think
it's a problem
I was told
that there had
obviously pictures
super cheap
very busy
my age
absolutely
I mean I may not get to do everything
yeah
I like your sweater
it looks very bright
oh it's okay
oh I've seen that tea here
oh
so do you know the world is just passing
Us by Kurt
I know yeah
that's right
um
OLS
it's already done
it prints it yeah oh no that is
the house
that has administrative services to that
what it is
is
foreign
set yesterday
um
thank you
problems
foreign
okay all right
all right um I'm gonna call the
executive session of the house Judiciary
Committee uh to order
and I'm first uh I'm going to take out
of order because we have a uh uh uh an
attorney here who worked significantly
on the amendment to House Bill 68 and if
anyone has questions she's the expert
and uh we can we can turn to her for her
knowledge so uh first I'm going to
recognize myself
to uh move the adoption of House Bill 68
and to offer Amendment
-436 and move the bill ought to pass
with Amendment do I have a second
I'll second it Mr chair
seconded by representative uh Alexander
um
all right
um so now what I'd like to what I'd like
to say and just in speaking about the
bill is as you may remember we had an
initial hearing on this bill
and um uh although I think
I'm I I think I'm characterizing this
correctly I think although we were we
were interested in the bill and thought
it might very well make sense there were
a number of witnesses who testified to
certain concerns about the bill and the
way it was left was that
um attorney Elise salik who testified
indicated that she and a group of
attorneys who are sort of experts in the
area of trust in Estates
and property law would be uh would try
to come together and come up with a
amendments uh or proposed changes to the
bill that would fix the concerns that
they raised true to her words she did
that and and submitted a proposal to me
which I uh which is now Incorporated an
amendment
0436h as I looked I looked at it quite
carefully and I actually had a couple of
questions about for lack of a better
term I'll sort of refer to them as
technical legal issues as I went through
the bill particularly dealing with the
issue of joint property ownership which
I spoke with uh attorney salic about and
she answered my questions you know uh to
my complete satisfaction so I what I
would say is I am am very comfortable
moving this amendment I think it is a
good proposal
that it will it will
provide another opportunity for people
who perhaps cannot afford to to obtain
the services of a lawyer for a will or
something like that we'll provide
another opportunity for for them to be
able to transfer property
and I guess with that I would ask are
there attorneys say like is here and I'd
ask if members of the committee have
questions about any aspects of the bill
she she's certainly the person that that
would be able to provide the most
authoritative answers I believe
to um
so I have any anyone have any yes uh
okay representative Perez please thank
you thanks for taking me my only concern
is
um
being a senior myself my only concern is
elderly people getting someone who to
force them to or coerce them into
signing this there's really you know
um you know a a young a child and a
parent with cognitive issues getting
them to sign this there's really no
protection but I guess there's no
protection and a will either for the
same type of things
actually in this statute
um there is protection built in and I
want to be clear that that was one of
the issues that my group and I had
identified about the original version
there wasn't protection built into the
original statute so we have addressed
that in in two ways first uh there's a
provision in the statute now that
requires that the capacity for entering
into one of these transfer on death uh
Deeds is the same as the capacity
required to make a will in New Hampshire
the second protection we built in and
this is new as of the last version is
that we have put in a mechanism whereby
if undue influence has occurred and if
family members or others suspect that
someone has been forced to sign one of
these Deeds there's now a mechanism
built into this statute that permits the
interested parties to go to court within
a specified period of time the same way
they'd have the opportunity to contest a
will and to make their case to the
Circuit Court probate division those
Provisions were not in the original bill
they currently are in the new version so
we feel that that has been addressed
because it was a concern thank you other
questions yes representative Macbeth
thank you thank you for taking my
question and thank you for your work
um I
I do have a question but I also am
curious as by what you said what
Provisions I see there is a protection
you said that you had added in two
things so I see um on page four Roman
numeral two
um no I think it's I'm sorry could you
reference what sections those
preferences no it's actually on page two
line three of the amendment
um line five it starts talks about the
capacity of the transfer or in the
requirements so that's one that's
correct and again that was in the
original statute but we what we didn't
have is the enforcement mechanism and
I'm not looking at the same version that
you're looking at but I can point you to
the section number thank you that uh
deals with the ability to question or or
deal with the validity so it's now under
uh what will be 563 D 17 the title of
that section is validity of transfer on
death deed
and it should be one
thank you okay so uh under Roman two of
that section it says an action to
contest the validity of a transfer under
the deed
etc etc must be commenced within the
later of and so that's the provision
that deals with the enforcement
mechanism I think so now my question
thank you so what I wonder is on the
sample the statutory sample of the bill
and the acknowledgment I know
I'm wondering why it doesn't say there I
know on the wills that I execute it says
this person freely exercised and is a
clear mind that's the that's right where
the person that's you know the notary or
attesting to it seems like that should
some of that should be there shouldn't
it well the reason we didn't put it
there is that because this is not a will
it is a deed and so the way this bill is
structured and it's similar in all other
29 states that have enacted transfer on
death Deeds is because we're putting a
deed on record at the registry of deeds
and we are not drafting a will uh Wills
here in New Hampshire require two
witnesses and a notary Deeds do not and
so we didn't want to create a situation
here where we're taking a deed which is
something everyone understands uh you
know how it operates and how it needs to
be signed and adding additional
requirements to this particular sort of
deed that don't
apply to other Deeds under RSA 477. this
is a deed it's not a will so yes one
needs the same capacity to sign this as
a will but it's not a will it's a
substitute and so because this is just a
deed it should be signed with the same
acknowledgment and formalities of any
other deed to be recorded under RSA 477
so that was a deliberate design on our
part so may I follow up yes of course so
how are we educating I mean if you're
notarizing this or affirming
acknowledging it
but you don't know if you're
acknowledging it as you should because
the statutory said I mean right here it
has the statutory requirements of a will
but you didn't put that in the
acknowledgment so it seems inconsistent
um and I'm worried that people that are
you know not attorneys are familiar with
what's the requirement when you're
affirming it or um or acknowledging it
you know well the answer to that
question is that this legislation
doesn't say that it has to be signed
with the formalities of a will it simply
says that the capacity required to sign
this is the same capacity as a will so
we've not said that the statutory
formalities that apply to signing Wills
apply to this deed
so I think you're incorrect in saying
that there could be confusion we're
simply saying that the capacity the
threshold for capacity for signing a
transfer on death deed is the same as
signing will but the statutory
formalities are not
other questions for this witness yes
representative Perez thank you I'm sorry
if someone signs this
and then they do a will
or a trust
okay
what comes first what supersedes the
other
legally the deed will supersede because
the deed sort of stands on its own so if
you have one of these transfer on death
deeds and you designate your daughter as
the recipient of your property when you
die and you subsequently enter into a
trust agreement
the deed will not be impacted by the
trust because the property that is the
subject of the transfer on death deed
isn't in the trust
one would have to sort of revoke the
transfer on death deed by either putting
an instrument of revocation on record at
the registry of deeds saying I revoke my
prior designation to my daughter
or one would have to take that property
and transfer it into the trust to revoke
the transfer on death deed but the
trance around death deed would Trump any
later instrument that doesn't actually
revoke the transfer on death deed follow
up yes
what if you already have a trust and a
will
and you have a trust that your property
is in or will that your property is in
but you want to do this
you can and so let's just take the
example that you provided you have a
trust your primary residences in that
trust and you decide that instead of
having the trust dictate how your
primary residence is going to be
distributed at death you want to pull
that property out of the trust and give
it to someone else you simply execute a
new deed
transferring the property out of the
trust
and designating it via one of these
transfer on death Deeds to that other
person
other questions representative
uh yeah thanks Mr chair and thanks for
taking the question
um I specifically and again this is this
is apologies for not understanding the
legal language here you had mentioned in
your original testimony
an issue with title companies not being
willing to to take these because
um of technical requirements and the the
register of deeds for my County also
made a same point and I couldn't reading
this see what has been changed in order
to fix that and I was wondering if you
could just explain well let me deal with
the registry of deeds issue first I
actually sent a copy of our edits to the
register of deeds who was here
testifying with some concerns about the
prior bill
she looked to this over and gave it the
green light and said we had addressed
her issues her issue really surrounded
around notice and making sure that when
the death occurs and there's one of
these transfer on death Deeds on record
that the decedent's death certificate
actually gets recorded at the registry
of deeds that's what causes the transfer
to occur and so there's a requirement in
the statute that says that once a
decedent dies having one of these
transformative death Deeds on record
that person's death certificate has to
be recorded in every County in which
Real Estate that's being transferred via
this deed is located so that's sufficed
to deal with her concerns
the issue of title companies is a little
bit trickier in the sense that from the
outset the precursor to this bill which
I believe was Senate Bill 243 was
something that caused title companies a
significant amount of heartburn
and when we were working as a
legislative group with title companies
to address SB 243 we received input from
the title companies and had addressed
some of their concerns
in the meantime House Bill 68 came down
the pike and it was quite a bit
different from the original Senate bill
243.
we invited the title companies to join
with us and to work on this draft
legislation we provided our contacts at
the title insurance companies with
copies of our revisions as we went along
uh and to our surprise we really didn't
get any further input from the title
companies so they were invited to work
with us to draft this statute I'm
disappointed to say that they didn't
join us in this effort and so I really
can't speak to whether or not they have
any continuing concerns I simply didn't
hear back from them
just one quick follow-up was there a
specific section of this that that you
know to be the the sticking point for
them
no uh the general comment I received was
from a woman at a local title company
here who also underwrites in Maine Maine
has had a transfer on death deed statute
now for several years
and what she recited to me was that in
general because of the potential for
creditor claims so in other words under
every version of a transfer on death
deed statute if you die with property
and you transfer it via one of these
Deeds to say your kid and the property
is mortgaged the mortgage follows the
property and so the person who inherits
the property inherits it subject to that
debt or any other encumbrances
the existence of that mortgage and that
encumbrance causes problems for title
companies so it was in the context of
encumbered property that the title
companies were concerned because if the
person who inherits the property then
ultimately tries to convey it to someone
else there's a question as to whether or
not the the title there is good that a
warranty deed can issue
we think we've resolved that issue here
by simply saying that if you convey
property versus be a transfer on death
deed it comes with no warranties
you get it subject to all encumbrances
and creditor claims even if you were to
make the mistake in drafting the deed
saying this comes with warranty
covenants it simply doesn't so to the
extent the title companies are concerned
that they'll somehow have to underwrite
policies on these transform death Deeds
we've made it easier than for them to do
that because there's no liability
attached to a a deed that comes you know
for on property that is fully encumbered
you can't convey this via warranty deed
even if you try
other questions yes representative
Macbeth hi thank you
so
um I'm looking on page four it's section
it's V five let me see um D14
it's line number 14 it says property
conveyed by transfer death shall not be
considered as part of the probate estate
for the of The spouse's right so does
that do away with the homestead um
it does it does not it does this bill
does not impact Homestead rights which
you know if you're an attorney have
worked in this area Homestead issues are
totally nebulous and it's very hard to
get your head around what that actually
means as a surviving spouse or in a
bankruptcy context so uh this bill
doesn't upset or deal with homestead in
any way
um all it does is allow you to transfer
that deed and not have it subject to
What's called the spousal elective share
in other words we're taking probate
Concepts and with separating them away
from Real Estate Concepts here so we
don't have people making claims in
Probate Court on property that has gone
out the door via transfer on death Deed
by virtue of the spousal election or the
pretermitted air statute
other questions could she explain the
spousal elective share and what that
does to the spouse that now that we're
eliminating that yes so we're not
eliminating spouse well you just said
you're eliminating the elective share so
elective shares could you explain that
absolutely so under New Hampshire law
um the general rule is that as a person
as a decedent you have the right to
convey your property to anyone you want
and if you happen to be married at the
time of your death and your will leaves
nothing to your surviving spouse then
that surviving spouse who has been
completely cut out of your will has the
right to go into probate court and
demand what's called an elective share
and under New Hampshire law that
elective share amount is one-third
and so the general notion in New
Hampshire is that spouses can freely
disinherit one another but the center
tax accidental or that the receiver the
surviving spouse doesn't like the fact
that he or she has been disinherited
that person has the right to redress in
the probate court by at least grabbing
one-third of the probate assets
cause this is a non-probate transfer
it's it's the same as taking your bank
account and putting a beneficiary in
your bank account you drop dead your
kid's name is on the benefit on the bank
account that kid walks into the bank
with your death certificate and the bank
hands your child the money this is what
we're trying to do with real estate the
same thing that people have been doing
for decades with their 401ks and
everything else
a bank account is not subject to the
elective share
a 401k well let's let's not go there
because that's subject to Federal rules
that don't apply ah a bank account is
not subject to the elective share so if
I die married
and I don't have my spouse on my bank
account and I instead name a child as
the recipient my spouse cannot claim a
one-third share of that bank account
it's not subject to the elective share
because the bank account is not a
probate asset so in answer to your
question what we've done with the
transfer on death deed statute because
we want real estate transfers via
transfer on death designation to operate
the same way that Financial transactions
do at the bank is that we have made the
transfer on death deed statute not part
of the one-third elective share that you
can elect again against if you are a
spouse who has not been left anything
so may I follow up yes so you people
been married for 50 years second
marriage children from the first
marriage get the dad who the name the
house is in the dad's name he dies he
signed the deed the stepmother who's
been married for 40 years she's evicted
from the house and
that there's nothing she can do she
can't claim her elective share
only that is correct but you are
presuming that the husband that the wife
in this situation is under already a
joint owner on the deet
if she is then that doesn't happen but
in this instance and and I see this
often in my practice in in second or
third marriage situations where a spouse
you know will pick on the husband here
so the husband remarries
he owns property in his own name and he
doesn't want his second spouse his third
spouse his fourth spouse to get that
property when he dies he wants to pass
it to his children he can do that via
the transfer on death statute
if however our husband has added wife
number two wife number three wife number
four whoever she is as a joint owner on
the property
then that surviving spouse the wife will
take when the husband dies because she's
already a joint owner on the property
and if she survives him then she's in
control of the property and she can
distribute it the way she wants to do
that so just one more question I'm going
back to this acknowledgment would you
consider adding into the acknowledgment
that acknowledged before me in
accordance with the RSA that says it has
to you know it has the capacity of a
will because I'm still concerned about
this when I sit down to a document to
acknowledge it if I'm just being a a
notary or Justice of the piece I follow
exactly what the instrument says and if
it just says acknowledge it then I just
make sure it's the person I don't ask
the other questions so I'm concerned
that people might be acknowledging this
based on what the document itself says
and it doesn't refer back to really what
that you have to check on capacity Free
Will whatever
so would you consider an amendment that
would at least add so it's not changing
and making standard but it says you know
acknowledging it in accordance with you
know RSA
563 I don't think I'd be comfortable
doing that for the following reason you
and I are attorneys we understand what
capacity is in terms of signing a will
the whole purpose of this transformed
death is indeed statute is to make sure
that people don't have to hire an
attorney
to convey their property
um
so and the other thing is that there's a
cross-reference here to RSA 477 and
again this is a deed and so if the idea
here is that a transfer on death deed
um
looks and and otherwise walks and talks
like any other deed
then adding an additional requirement
that refers to the capacity
uh requires us to then make other
changes to RSA 477 and then it's not a
New Hampshire deed that looks like any
other New Hampshire deed so I just have
to clarify so you just said we don't
want to put a reference to a statute
because the person that's acknowledging
it may not be able to interpret the
statute and be able to say that the
person's has capacity but they're
acknowledging this document I mean that
makes no sense you know what I'm sorry I
I mean it seems like we're kind of
getting into debate as opposed to
questions and I'm not I'm not sure that
that really is helpful
um are there other questions for this
witness yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair
um I want I wanted to ask a question
about capacity also and the question of
that representative Perez raised the
question of person a person having
capacity at one point in time to do the
the deed and then subsequently later
their their capacity changes and you
would need it's a question but wouldn't
you need a power of attorney at that
point if there were going to be a
subsequent change
um let's say the daughter knows that her
mother would want to change it
so you would need a power of attorney at
that point would you not to make a
subsequent change when there's lack of
capacity yes and you actually need more
than just a power of attorney and that
is one of the issues that we addressed
when we made revisions to hb68 so our
initially we questioned as a drafting
group whether or not someone who holds a
power of attorney should have the
authority to convey property on behalf
of an incapacitated person via one of
these transfer and death Deeds and what
we ultimately uh agreed to and and
determined would be you know fair and
Equitable is to put a provision in this
bill that specifically allows the holder
or an agent under a power of attorney to
engage in one of these transactions
subject to all of the normal fiduciary
duties that apply to every transaction
that an agent enters into under a power
of attorney and also subject to the
further requirement that the durable
power of attorney specifically authorize
that agent to make changes to
beneficiary designations so if the
mother in your example has a durable
power of attorney that specifically
allows the agent to change beneficiary
designations then that language would
permit that daughter to engage in one of
these transactions on her mother's
behalf
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Horton
another day yet I'm not an expert on the
definition of a person but a few years
ago and it was on an unrelated area of
the law
I discovered that um well it was
interference with custody which turned
out the interferency custody law didn't
cover the case where someone was
interviewing with custody of the dcyf
because the dcya that's not a person I
know there's going to be a question here
thank you yes sir this is a definition
of person which includes government
agencies but I know
in other areas of the law
government agencies are not considered
persons so is that
is that something that maybe we need to
tweak to cause less confusion or are you
happy with it or did you do that uh or
you think this is the best solution the
problem of what to do if you want to
transfer the property on death to a
government agency
I think this this bill has a definition
of person uh and as you mentioned that
is broadly defined and person doesn't
just mean an individual it could be in a
state it could be a trust it could be a
Business Partnership so we wanted to
give individuals and entities of which
those individuals are a member the
broadest possible opportunity to convey
so this definition of person is
consistent with the definition of person
that is found in the acts of all 29
other states that have passed transfer
on death legislation so I'm not
anticipating any problems I've not heard
of any problems with the definition of
person
other questions for this week
by seeing none again attorney
silica I want to thank you and your
group so much for your I know you put a
lot of work into this uh and it and and
it shows for sure and your quest your
your presentation here today has been
very helpful so thank you on behalf of
the committee and thank you for giving
us an opportunity to tweak this and make
it better for the citizens of New
Hampshire we really appreciate it
thank you all right
um so um
uh the on HB uh 68
um I guess we're we're I'm ready for
other Is there further discussion on the
bill
and I guess we have to I and the
amendment I should say we first have to
vote on that but is there further
discussion on the amendment
all right seeing none um I I
think we can have a Voice vote unless
anybody objects on the amendment and
then we would have to have a roll call
pardon a show of hands a show of hands
on the amendment unless anybody objects
to that procedure
right seeing none then I've got all
those in favor of the amendment uh to uh
House Bill 68 amendment number
20230436h please raise your hand
it appears it is unanimous
all right
um
then turning to
uh the bill as Amendment amended as any
any further discussion on on that or are
we ready for a vote on the bill as
amended
but here's we are so I would ask the
clerk to please call the roll on we want
to make an OTP motion I'm sorry I should
I move uh otpa on House Bill 68. is
there a second
yeah
well he seconded for the amendment
emotions oh okay that's fine okay all
right so it's been moved and seconded
and I think we're ready for a roll call
vote
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes rep chap YES Prep
Grayson yes
clerkutab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith yes reporter again
no
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes
rep page yes Rhett Macbeth
so
Brett Brennan yes
rep Lanza
rep Manos no
rapture
yes
chairman Lynn yes
17 years three Nays motion passes
um in light of the vote I think it
probably uh should not go on consent and
um representative kutab would you write
the majority report on this and is there
going to be a Minority Report
oh I'll write one all right so
um
yeah and so um
I'd like to have the reports uh all the
reports we're gonna of the things we're
gonna exec today by the close of
business tomorrow and when I say close
of business I mean if you know I mean
midnight tomorrow night so if you say if
you work on it tomorrow night and get it
to me uh by email by tomorrow night
that's that's good enough for me
make one quick comment I want to make
sure that everyone knows when I enter my
next profession it is not going to be
real estate Wills trusts or a state
yes
all right
um
all right good all right so then that
takes care of
533 I'm now going to turn to uh
cacr2 and I'm going to recognize myself
to make a motion uh of inexpedient to
legislate and look to representative
Wallace second all right so that motion
has been made and seconded
um
and I guess I would I would initially uh
say this with regard to that and then
obviously we'll open it to a discussion
um
it seems to me
and as as many of you
probably know if uh I'm sure I'm sure
remember the committee now if you ask me
to sort of characterize myself as being
pro-life for pro-choice I would
characterize myself as pro-choice
um although I do believe
that um which is why I supported the
fetal Life protection act that there
comes a point
um at which they're at which the
pregnancy has preceded so far that that
the state does have a strong interest in
saying that in an ability to to uh
regulate and to say no you can't have an
abortion after this point
and I know that there are people have
different views on this issue
I hope that the people who
would be inclined to support cacr2
will consider this
it seems to me that what you are doing
by this amendment is you're not if to
the extent that you want to give
greater protection to the right to an
abortion
you're not doing it in this bill
for example if there were if if there
was a proposed Constitutional Amendment
that said
no abortions no abortions I'm sorry
there's a right to an abortion up to 24
weeks up to up until 24 weeks of
pregnancy with certain exceptions in
other words if you were to take the
fetal Life protection act and propose it
as a constitutional amendment
I don't know how I feel if I might be
willing to support that I'm not sure I
still might have some concern about
should it should we really put this in
the Constitution but maybe maybe I could
be persuaded in that
but what you've done by this proposed
amendment is you've essentially said
we're going to throw this to the court
we're going to allow Mr chair I'd like
to I'd hate to interrupt you but I'd
like to object if you want to tell us
why you want to vote itl I think that's
perfectly appropriate but I don't really
think you should be telling us what the
other side wants
um or what the other side expects in
this there may be many reasons one of
which I've heard from a number of your
colleagues for example that this is an
issue where we should let the people of
the state decide so I would love to hear
why you are voting the way you are but I
don't really think it's helpful for you
to decide why other people are voting
the way they are thank you I'm not sure
that I but thank you and I'm pretty sure
I'm not sure that I was was
saying what other people are doing but I
guess what I what I would say is this
if the purpose of this
is to Grant a greater right to abortion
than exists now
I I think that that
is not accomplished by this amendment
because what as I said before what it
does
is
um it says uh and I'm quoting now that
an individual's right to personal
reproductive autonomy is Central to uh
is Central to the liberty and dignity to
determine one's own life course and
shall not be denied or infringed unless
justified by a compelling State interest
achieved by the least restrictive means
so
what does that mean does that mean that
they that if if this Constitutional
Amendment were to pass
that the current fetal Life protection
act is unconstitutional
you can't read this some some people may
say well there's a compelling State
interest
achieved by the least restrictive means
um uh by having an abort having a
Prohibition on abortion of 24 weeks and
some people might say no that's not true
the the the the the the compelling State
interest arises earlier or later
what you've what you but by passing this
Constitutional Amendment what
effectively will be done is you will you
will say Court
you decide what you will what what the
what the Constitution requires and we
will have
on the state level we will have a Roe v
Wade uh uh I I will have our own Roe v
Wade and all the controversy surrounding
Roe v Wade on the state level and stop
and think of some of the implications of
that when somebody gets when Mr chairman
you're speaking of the right of abortion
but in New Hampshire are you supporting
HB 88 that would codify that because
there is is there a right to have an
abortion in New Hampshire I'm going to
make sure everybody has an opportunity
no but I'm just you're speaking of the
right to have an abortion in New
Hampshire what are you basing that on
what I'm I'm speaking about the right to
have an abortion in New Hampshire what
am I basing it on because there's no
prohibition on the right to have an
abortion in New Hampshire right now
except if it's after 24 if uh if it's
after 24 weeks so what I was as I was
saying you're gonna
you're going to place this is you're
going to place this issue basically
this amendment throws this issue to the
Supreme Court and says a supreme court
you decide let five people decide what
when does a compelling State interest
arise is it at 24 weeks or 21 weeks or
never
a person should have the right to
abortion right to lead to the very end
let the Court decide and consider some
of the implications of having Roe versus
Wade at the state level
how about when you know it's been it's
been with with one really unfortunate
exception
the way judges have been selected in New
Hampshire has been pretty bipartisan for
quite a number of years Republican
Governors have selected Democratic
judges and Democratic Governors have
selected Republican judges and in
general
with you know maybe one or two
exceptions we've avoided the kind of
thing that has happened at the national
level
but when you say to the court you decide
Court as a state constitutional matter
you decide when the right of abortion
exists and what the what the limitations
are
what will be the what will be the
implications of that for the next time
that someone's up for for a nomination
to the Supreme Court
um so that's that's a summary of why I
intend to support itl on this bill and I
open it up to further discussion
representative Turk
um yeah I
um
oppose the itl motion um I have I have a
lot to say uh that I'll probably Reserve
in case the itl motion does not succeed
and there's a future motion um made the
one thing I will point out though is
um and thank you for reading the text of
that key phrase in in this bill
um I agree it's not specifically an
abortion Bill obviously it encompasses
and probably its reason for being for us
is is heavily related to that but it it
talks about two things reproductive
freedom
which goes far beyond terminations
um and gets at all forms of uh
reproductive decisions and choice and
the other thing is it doesn't specify
women or the medical profession as some
of the restrictions have it basically
talks about the right of all people to
make that choice men and women and
families so I just wanted to sort of
make sure we had the right perspective
on what we would be itling if we were to
go for this motion all right other
comments representative Horgan
well thank you first of all you know
what a ropey wage situation but Ruby
Wade actually survived for a pretty long
time and it took a pretty concerted
effort to get rid of it so um
that may have not been such a terrible
terrible example and I'm not I think
there probably are some issues related
to reproductive Freedom that maybe the
courts which have a lot to do with the
details of like a Pacific
uh person's situation so perhaps the
courts may be a more appropriate venue
than the legislature to solve all these
all these issues but um
my main thing is reproductive Freedom
it's not just about abortion it's also
about whether or not to uh
whether or not to you know whether or
not you can be become pregnant in the
first place like whether or not you can
like uh whether or not
whether or not you have a full choice of
means of birth control it also uh
as we see with the ongoing debate over
uh transgender rights uh concerns like
whether you have certain uh surgeries
gender affirming surgeries and also like
certain procedures that uh CIS people
have and also it even has to do with uh
some of the decisions
um
you make like after the baby is born
like whether you can force people to
give it up for adoption and stuff so
that's a very broad range of
broad range of issues I think this
amendment or something like provides a
much broader range of uh
you know water you've lost a much
broader range of issues rather than just
the abortion and of course actually the
24 week thing that's kind of a magic
number that we've kind of arrived at but
it's actually like a pretty
arbitrary number like some fetuses are
viable at 24 weeks um some aren't and
even the ones are viable like takes
pretty uh
it takes you know like a you know pretty
major intervention to keep them alive
long enough to get to uh the point where
they should be which is more like I
think 37 or 38 weeks normally so I think
um
so I think this uh
I think this amendment is uh I think
this amendment is worthwhile
um and uh if we have issues with precise
wording uh we could
we could always of course uh retain it
because the people can't vote on it
until 2024 anyway since there's no
general election in 2023 so it doesn't
uh
if the feeling is if the feeling is
amongst the proposed Ito that they would
like to do something but they don't like
that exact wording there is plenty of
time to have a subcommittee to decide on
a slightly different wording but I think
it's a
I think it's excellent as is and covers
show the full range of reproductive
choices which is not just the choice of
whether or not to have a portion of 24
weeks because you know far beyond that
so I would
so I would certainly I'm certainly not
going to vote for the uh itl motion so
thanks all right other Comics
representative Manos
thank you Mr chair
um I will start
the itl on this your itl motion but I
wanted to point out that um certainly
reproductive
um reproductive Freedom includes in
addition to abortion and birth control
sterilization and I think I think we
need to keep that in mind that
reproductive freedom is a very broad
range of reproductive choices but the
other point I want to make is in
response to your argument Mr chair
these are all arguments that will be
presented to the people of New Hampshire
to consider and decide and I feel very
very strongly that democracy with a
small the Democratic Values small the
um are very very important and that we
need to let the people of New Hampshire
make a decision on this and that that is
what we should move forward with so I
will be opposing the Ito other uh yes
representative Staples Stapleton yeah
thank you Mr chair um
kind of concur with what you scoped out
before
to some extent
um
and I but I believe the bill is
problematic
um on the on line five uh right from the
beginning the two words unless Justified
followed by compelling State interest
opens this up to State standing
for the state obligation to challenge
um an abortion that they that might come
into that scope of violating the
compelling State interest
and if you open up standing on that
basis how about other interested parties
to have standing like the father
the other problem I have with this is
missing unless otherwise prohibited by
law
so we would have a conflict in law
between the partial birth abortion ban
that we have already on the books and
the six-month prohibition
so I see technical problems with this
which is why I'll support the itl
other comments
see up yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair I will be supporting
the itl motion I think that words have
meanings or they're supposed to have
meanings but if we continue to change
the definitions of words then everything
is meaningless and nothing and no one
matters and laws become unenforceable
and rights become undefendable so the
very Foundation of civilization crumbles
and cacr2 uses some very broad language
that opens up the possibility for the
normalization of some pretty weird stuff
for example we can't use the term
pedophile anymore because that might be
stigmatizing they're now called minor
attracted persons as that sort of
behavior is becoming more normalized and
more popular so cacr2 would enable these
persons to make their own reproductive
decisions to pursue their childhood
dreams and since we must not marginalize
or stigmatize people brothers and
sisters would be allowed to keep it in
the family and it wouldn't be the first
time in history that it was done but now
we would be saying that that could be
done again here and lastly some people
love animals more than people so those
with that Affinity would be able to
engage in that behavior unless you think
I'm extreme Spain just changed their
Animal Welfare Law to make bestiality
legal as long as no injury requiring
Veterinary Care results from the act
because as the sponsor of the new law
said zoophiles are just another Spectrum
on the trans flag
on a more sane note
what reproductive decisions do the
biological fathers of pre-born babies
have the right to make according to the
testimony that was heard the only
decision the man has is the right to
keep his mouth shut he chose to have sex
but that's as far as it goes he didn't
choose to get her pregnant but now that
she is his rights are over because no
uterus no opinion now the Supreme Court
has stated the United States Supreme
Court has stated that her rights are
given the greater weight not that he has
no rights at all so perhaps the law
should say what the law should do is say
that she gets the right of first refusal
if she doesn't want to keep the baby she
doesn't have to but before any further
action is taken he should have the right
to step in and take responsibility for
his actions and keep the baby himself if
she choose if he should choose to do so
perhaps the law needs to lay out this
right and a mechanism for how this can
be done cacr2 is is horribly flawed and
should be inexpedient to legislate other
comments
before we all right are we ready for a
vote the motion uh before the before us
is um my motion of itl and I would ask
the clerk to call the roll please
chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
yes
rep Stapleton YES Prep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
clerkutab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep Eaton
rep page no Brett Macbeth no prep
Brennan no
rep lonza
no
rap Manos no
ripped her no
chairman Lynn yes
motion bails 10 to 10.
is there another motion yeah
I'm sorry representative
all right representative sir
uh yeah I I would like to make the
motion of ought to pass
ion's been made and second would you
like to speak to your motion
representative yes thank you
um so uh I'll rehash a little bit of
what I said a moment ago
um this is a bill that's much broader
than uh the question of uh termination
of pregnancy
um it gets at the entire spectrum of
reproductive Freedom
um
which impacts
various aspects that that relate to men
as well as as to women we talked about
their their
um vasectomy would be would be covered
by this uh all forms of contraception
um things like that uh would be covered
by this and the other thing is it it
doesn't specify that it's just about
women and and about their medical care
it's about all individuals
um being able to make those decisions
for themselves and uh the part that I
think you called out as the flaw I think
is is is the important part of it which
is it does leave a provision for
compelling State interest it does say
that
some of the things that representative
Grayson mentioned
um there would be a compelling State
interest and and that would that would
still be allowable under under this
amendment so
um let me go on a little bit uh in terms
of why this is needed um so I want to
point out not to not to make it sound
too momentous but it is this is the
first vote like this ever in the New
Hampshire house this is the first vote
um that comes after a federal
constitutional right was reversed and
delegated back to state legislators to
decide how to handle it
um
Dobbs versus Jackson Women Health Center
was was a bill about abortion but the
concurrence of that uh justice Thomas
specifically called into question other
aspects that are covered by
um the right to privacy including
contraception so I do think it's
important that we keep the the framework
of what we're suggesting here
um in focus and this is not to deny that
this bill is probably here because of
the question of of abortion
um but but I think that's too narrow
Focus so why ought to pass
um
again that that decision at the Supreme
Court level
um did not specifically make abortion
legal or not illegal it just returned
the power to the states
um
the first thing I feel like we should do
with this new power that has been given
to us
um by the federal government is to offer
it back to the people that have had this
right for 50 years
supporting this cacr2 amendment is about
Freedom it is about Liberty at their
deepest level these are private
decisions they're about families they're
about our bodies they're about our
health
um we are not making the decision by
supporting this amendment
um we are asking the people if they want
this right that they've enjoyed for 50
years back
or if we as legislators should be the
ones to continue to make these decisions
so if this is adopted I would say we
would be moving more or less to the
status quo that people have become
accustomed to
um it would it would be only in the
state's uh interest to to restrict
reproductive Freedom
um if not we will continue hearing many
bills every year pro and con on this
issue uh if you look at what we're
hearing this year the range of bills
goes from what we're hearing now
constitutional amendment to uh uh the
these the heartbeat bill which would
essentially ban all abortions so this is
hardly a settled um
place for the legislature to be
intervening
um
that that will be a choice people will
make when they go to the ballot and and
either pass or not pass this
Constitutional Amendment needing
three-fifths support in order to do it
so this will not be a decision made
lightly by the people in New Hampshire
if
um this is presented to them I want to
also talk to a couple of things that I
think we heard during the testimony
um one of them is are we talking about
an unrestricted right that was just
discussed a minute ago I'll say not
really
um
what the bills we've seen already around
um termination of pregnancy
uh focus on the medical profession and
the medical profession I will
um
put forward is a heavily and
successfully self-regulated profession
in our state and I think we should keep
it that way a few things that Physicians
and practitioners other practitioners
work with under their Hippocratic Oath
the licensure restrictions their
standards of care extensive standards of
care around how um
pregnancy and reproduction need to be
handled there are ethics review
committees at every organization where a
procedure could be performed that would
that would come into play if anything uh
that's that seemed unethical was was
being requested then there are insurance
company rules that dictate what can be
done and their malpractice laws that can
also dictate the profession so it is not
an unrestricted right
um and and the things that we've heard
about in the testimony some terrible
abuses that we heard about in the
testimony
um
those were not
related to reproductive Freedom those
were criminal acts that we were told
about happening in other states and the
people who committed them one person in
particular that was highlighted you know
is serving three consecutive life
sentences for that and I asked whether
or not that person could be prosecuted
under current New Hampshire law and the
answer was yes most likely so so I think
we already have plenty of restrictions
uh prohibitions against that so I'm just
going to sum up and say
we have to ask ourselves
um the question before us really isn't
about whether abortion should be legal
or not I actually somewhat agree this
does not settle the case completely that
that it will or will not
um but it says that there's a individual
right to make your reproductive choices
your most personal uh choices you make
in your whole life so we're really
asking by by whether we um pass this or
not if we know better than the people
across the state what's best for them
and if they want us involved in this
decision or not and I'm going to say
that uh voting no simply says that we
don't trust the people of New Hampshire
to make the right decisions for
themselves
I hope we will vote
ought to pass on this and put it before
the people of New Hampshire to decide in
this new environment that that very few
of uh the people of our state have lived
under
um for the in in their in their lives
um whether they want that right back or
not thank you all right other uh
comments yes representative Oregon
um yes I I agree with everything
represent representative from Exeter
just said as I said there's a lot more
to reproductive freedom than just
abortion and uh Ruby Wade was superseded
by the Dobbs decision but that's
probably a fairly narrow decision it
took a very very concerted effort to
overturn it so it's probably
would have been better for the country
to leave Roe v Wade in place but that's
um not where that's not what you are so
I don't I don't think the Specter of a
Roe v Wade situation New Hampshire
scares me as much as I think I trust our
court system even though I probably
um maybe more than some people do but as
a practical matter where we are now to
pass it we're going to need 240 votes on
the floor so that's going to take
it's obviously gonna take a lot of uh a
lot of people a lot of people um a lot
of people in a certain political party
will have to change their minds
significantly from where they are now so
I think um
I mean I'd love to see that happen but I
think that's uh
that's going to take that's going to
take a fairly remarkable chain of events
to make it happen so I think there's uh
I think there's no point in sending it
to this floor now if we're not in
agreement but um I would certainly
prefer to vote for
for although I certainly uh support the
ought to pass motion and if we're lucky
uh for Lucky maybe we will get those 240
votes so I'm sure I'm sure everyone will
be lobbied very hard on all sides of the
issue so I uh I look forward to voting
for for ought to pass so and hopefully
someday this amendment will pass I'd
like to see it happen in 2024 but
it might be some other year thanks other
Comics yes representative
yes um so necessarily you know when we
think about reproductive productive
Freedom we're not only thinking about
well as I say like we said
um terminations abortions we're also
thinking about birth control and
sterilizations and
um we really need to think about I know
when I knocked on my doors and became a
state rep here I can tell you the amount
of people
not only females males as well who were
very concerned that we've lost a lot
within our country and not and within
our state so I am here today to make
sure that I'm standing up for ought to
pass and it's very important
um I'm a nurse as well so it's very very
important that we make sure that we
stand strong thank you other comments on
this bill on this yeah yes
representative Staples
thank you Mr chair
if I were a proponent of this bill
which I'm not but if I were
one of the things that I would include
was some of the stuff that the sponsor
talked about in testimony to Define
reproductive freedom
including contraception abortion
sterilization
forced or voluntary
number of children or no children
there's no adequate definition it could
be anybody's subjective interpretation
and that's going to be a problem for
action and defense
the other thing is is that when we tend
to to make a lot of assumptions that the
only thing that Dobbs did was overturn
row and throw it back to the States
but the first thing it did was declare
that there is no constitutional right to
abortion and then it throws it back to
the States
and if there's no constitutional right
to abortion on a federal level
we are as States subscribe to the
Federal Constitution linked
to that decision
and so we need to keep that in mind as
much as the state authority to act
independently on whatever it decides to
do in these type of cases
thank you other comments all right it
looks like we're up I'm sorry
representative Manos
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
respond to representative Stapleton and
what he just said
um certainly a state constitution can be
more protective than than the Federal
Constitution and so we're certainly
within our rights to put forward a
proposed state constitution to protect
Reproductive Rights certainly that's
permissible and then I absolutely trust
the people of New Hampshire to think
these issues through all the issues that
have been raised and to make their
decision and I just strongly support a
democratic process for for the citizens
of New Hampshire the voters of New
Hampshire to make their decision on the
these critically important issues all
right thank you other representative
yeah I just wanted to add one more thing
also also related to what representative
Stapleton said uh regarding the lack of
a definition of reproductive Freedom uh
I just want to point out that we are at
a time where we have unprecedented
technology regarding reproduction and
that technology covers the prevention of
pregnancy it covers the termination of
pregnancy but it also covers the other
side of the spectrum the the creation of
life we have the ability to create uh
life outside of the womb uh and and and
continue it there are there are various
iterations of that you know that have
happened over decades across the country
that's part of reproductive Freedom as
well and the technology continues to
evolve I think
uh the concept of reproduction is at the
core of the definition of reproductive
freedom and I think that's pretty
clearly defined all right other comments
all right I seeing none I guess we're
ready for a vote the uh uh the motion on
the floor is ought to pass all right ask
the clerk to call the roll please Vice
chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rep chip
no rep Grayson no
clerky tab votes no rep Perez
rep Smith
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes yes reppage yes Brett Macbeth yes
Rhett Brennan yes rep lonza yes we're at
Manos YES Prep chair yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
sure yes
yes chair recognizes representative
Smith thank you very much
um these are such difficult votes for
all of us and
um emotionally intellectually
philosophically
um I would like to suggest that we at
this point agree to send this uh to the
floor without recommendation and
understanding your previous commitment
that we use this as a natural time to
take a little breath a little break
catch
catch our breath and come back again at
whatever time you tell us to come back I
I very much appreciate that and I think
you're absolutely right you know just
one thing I can I say um just before we
uh we break
um I'll write the report in favor of itl
and I'm wondering if uh who will write
the report of OTP representative tour is
going to write that sure okay great
thank you
um
uh tomorrow evening
in the eastern time before
and as I as I said before at Repertory
you know if like if you get it to me by
midnight that's fine I don't care if
it's in the evening I know we have a
session tomorrow so it's yeah uh all
right all right so let's take we're
gonna I'm gonna recess the executive
session now and we will resume at let's
say one o'clock
um that that will give you enough time I
think yeah um
and and the next bill that we will take
up will be House Bill 88. all right
thank you
yeah
oh okay all right great
oh okay
oh three six eight which that's the one
so
um what I'd like to do then is is turn
to House Bill 88 I won't make a motion
at this point or ask I won't turn to
representative Perez yet but I guess I'd
like to just sort of have
um a general uh discussion on hb88 and
representative Perez is there any
without we're not going to talk about
the motion yet but do you want to do you
have a do you want to just generally
speak to hb88
I'm not here to represent myself
I am here to represent my constituents
so now now now now so I've I'm gonna I'm
turning to HB 88 I'm going to recognize
representative Perez for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to itl HB 88.
they're a second
I'll second Mister oh second oh go ahead
uh
they're Alexander seconds yes Alexander
seconds all right representative Perez
now do you want to speak to your motion
yes yes as I was saying I am a pro-life
Advocate as most of you know
um but I am not here to represent myself
I was put here by my constituents and my
constituents
um have been told overwhelmingly you
know more than 61
believe that we need to have some type
of
um believe in the fetal Life protection
act many of them did not know what it
was and I was quick to educate them
because there was so much misinformation
out there
but in finding out about it and knowing
about it I believe that my constituents
are very content with keeping the fetal
like protection act as it is now not
changing it now and moving forward so
therefore I would like to propose that
we itl this Bill thank you all right
anyone else wish to speak to uh house
bill 88.
Mr chair I wouldn't thank you
representative Alexander I I appreciate
it um house full 88 would create a um
private right of action
um and would award injunctive relief
um typically I've been opposed to
creating additional rights of actions um
so that's the reason why I'll be voting
against this Bill thank you
anyone else wish to speak to uh House
Bill 88 I guess the only thing that I
would say on House Bill 88 is I am going
to support the the itl
um motion because
it's not clear to me
exactly what this bill accomplishes
um if I understand it correctly it says
that it's that except
except as the fetal Life protection act
prohibits
um uh
uh abortion
um abortion is allowed and so I I that
but that's already the law
so what do we need this for and and
since this would only be a bill I mean a
law as opposed to a constitutional
amendment it would be
it would be sort of repeating what the
law already is and it would only be
valid until the law was changed so I'm
I'm not sure I see the value of of
having it so that that's that's
basically why I'm going to vote ICL
anyone else wish to speak to yes
representative Manos
um I just wanted to respond to
representative Alexander it's my
understanding that the enforcement in 88
only applies to State actors and not to
private actors and
um that it would not
um uh cause a private right of action as
to private actors
anyone else wish to speak to it
all right um all right so the motion
before us then on House Bill 88 is in
expedient to legislate
um and I'll ask the clerk to please call
the roll
Vice chairman Wallace
yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rap trip
yes rep Grayson yes quirkutab votes yes
rep Perez yes
rep Smith
rep hoorigan no
Reptil Lorenzo
uh for HP 88 for hb88
no Ito useful no
rep Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no
Brett Brennan no
replanza no rep Manos no Rapture no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
is there another
I'd like to represent I recognize
representative savings I would like to
make a motion of ought to pass
your second
all right would you like to speak to
your emotion now representative thank
you thank you Mr chair
um let me just start by saying what this
bill is not this is not a bill that
alters the fetal protection act it
doesn't change any of the current
restrictions on that were were placed on
abortion access
although some of us would like in
another
bill but um this is a straightforward
codification of the right
for for abortion care before 24 weeks I
think we had heard testimony in the
context of the Constitutional cacr-2
about what Dobbs did and the questions
that left for folks in terms of States
and what states are prepared to do or
not do and what this does is it puts
Clarity around that we acknowledge I
think in the context of that debate that
the right does exist although it is not
in State Statute this simply solves that
problem it makes clear what the right is
and that it provides that Clarity
um
I think that we should remember
that the vast majority of granite
Staters support access to abortion care
and that's what this guarantees it makes
it a positive right in State Statute we
right now in New Hampshire are an island
in New England in terms of
recognizing those protections we are the
only New England state that doesn't have
a statute like this
um other states are in fact recognizing
the need to clarify the right and in
fact if if I recall correctly 16 States
since the Dobbs decision have put in
similar legislation to this so this is a
very straightforward bill I think it
simply recognizes what we've already
heard in other contexts of other bills
and testimony in terms of
that the right exists but we don't see
it codified in the state law and that's
what this bill would do thank you Mr
chair all right
anyone else wish to speak to uh the the
ought to pass motion on House Bill 88.
seeing none I guess we're ready for a
vote I'm sorry to ask the clerk to
please call the roll Vice chairman
Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rap trap
no rep Grayson no clerkatab votes no rep
Perez
rep Smith
rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
rep Eaton yes
yes rep page yes Rhett McBeth yes rep
Brennan yes rep lonza
yes Brett Manos yes repter yes
chairman Lynn no
motion bails 10 to 10.
um so
um representative Perez uh you will
write the report in support of itl may I
ask that sure who will write the report
on uh OTP represent
um
yes I just want to apologize for my
confusion about HB 88 when I said what
Bill are we talking about a lot of
people were referring to it as a fetal
Life protection act
um which is
the next bill is 224 repealing the fetal
Life protection act so I got a little
confused I'm sorry no no no no no
apologies necessary it happened it
happens to all of us from time to time
for sure
um all right so next I'm going to turn
to
um
uh House Bill
224 hang on one second I find it here
2.4 all right and I'm going to uh
recognize myself for a motion of uh
inexpedient to legislate representative
greeson do you have a second
I will second that all right
uh and I'd like to speak to uh the
motion this this bill proposes to repeal
the criminal and civil penalties uh
or the fetal life uh protection act
and I think
basically the reason that I support this
that I do not support repealing the
criminal civil penalties is it seems to
me that they are a vital part of the ACT
and I guess what what I would say is the
I've heard two arguments advanced
in opposition to uh in support of
repealing the civil and criminal
penalties
um and they were made I think very
articulately by the people we heard at
the hearing most of many medical
professionals
the first argument was
abortions that would be that would
subject a doctor to civil or criminal
penalties under the ACT don't happen
they just never happen
so you know the kind of glib answer to
that is to say okay so then what's the
problem we passed this law there'll be
no there'll never be a prosecution
there'll never be any civil penalties
because these things don't happen
that's the kind of short answer to the
to the to that assertion but I think
that there's more
there's a bit more substance to what
those people are saying and I think in
some respect they have a they have a a
valid concern to a point
but what they're really asking for is a
special is that the law
have a special treatment of doctors and
here's what I mean by that
the argument is that well
there could be close cases there might
be cases in which a post-24-week
abortion was performed and
there were circumstances there was some
question about the season about the
whether the the abortion was necessary
to to save the life of the mother or
avoid the mother being and having some
severe health problem or there could be
questions as to the viability of the
fetus after 24 weeks
um uh and so you know those close
questions are a reason for uh
for not uh for why we we don't want to
uh subject doctors to some somehow the
risk that this uh that they would be
prosecuted
there's there's a couple of things that
I think are
really important to understand about
this
and that is that
um
the
the the I'll I'll Focus particularly on
the criminal penalties because that
seemed to be the thing that was a was
was uh argued the most strongly it's
really important to understand that the
criminal penalties under the fetal Life
protection act now
criminalize knowing conduct that means
that the doctor has to know that the
fetus above is over 24 weeks and that
there's no ex there's no threat to the
life of that or the health of the mother
or the fetal or there's no question
about the uh the the viability of the
fetus it it criminalizes knowingly
violating the law
and to the extent that the doctors are
are the Health Care Professionals are
arguing well there could be close cases
yeah I would agree there could be close
cases sometimes
why is that a basis for having a special
rule for doctors
as a lawyer I know from my back from my
background and both as a lawyer and as a
prosecutor that there are times when
when lawyers are charged for example in
Securities fraud cases or other things
are charged where there the the question
that there can be close cases what
exactly did the lawyer know about
whether this representation was true or
not uh that kind of thing
uh and yet we don't have a special rule
for lawyers
more importantly and I think really more
more maybe more in in sort of in terms
of the news of what people are sort of
have in their minds now let's consider
the situation of police officers police
officers are generally far less Highly
Educated than doctors
paid considerably less than doctors and
are often in a situation where they have
to make Split Second decisions where
life and death is at stake and yet
if they are if the evidence shows that
they knowingly
knowing let's say knowingly shot someone
where there was no valid basis for
claiming self-defense even though there
might be some issues about well did the
person really was a person really
running or how big a threat did the
person pose did they did the officer
really reasonably believe that it was a
gun that was being drawn or was it you
know it turns out it wasn't we don't
have a special rule for for police
officers if the if the if the if the
evidence will show that they will permit
a fact finder to find that they
knowingly
um uh uh extra used used unjustifiable
Force they can be criminally prosecuted
and held responsible even though there
may be as I just said cases where it's a
very close call
what the doctors are really asking for
here is a special rule they want to have
the the law be special as to them and I
know I would just make one final point I
had a discussion with uh with the right
with the ranking member I thought a very
a very uh productive discussion I
thought
in which one of the issues that was
raised well is well couldn't they be why
do you need the criminal penalty
couldn't the doctor be prosecuted for
murder and the answer to that is no
because the because right now it is not
murder
to abort a a fetus it is that is that is
not the crime of murder and nothing and
without the criminal penalties in the in
the fetal Life protection act there
would be no penalty for performing a
post-24-week abortion
um when there's no exceptions to the
fetal Life protection act and when the
doctor knows that there's no exception
to the fetal Life protection act so for
those reasons I think that it would be
repealing the criminal penalties would
be wellness and the Civil penalties
would be a very bad idea and that's why
I plan to support Ito
other people wish to speak to
representative Smith thank you very much
and I guess I need to ask your advice
I could take a couple of minutes now to
talk
or I could not talk now we could vote
on the pending motion and then if by
some chance the vote ends up to be 10 10
I could then speak in more detail should
I do that I'll leave it entitled to you
I have no whichever you prefer is fine
with me
well when why don't I speak now so I
don't forget what I was going to say uh
um
I listened to everything you said
and it seemed to me that you were making
a very strong argument in favor of this
bill until you got to the conclusion
when you said you weren't because what
this bill does is say that we should not
single out doctors we should not
treat doctors in a different in a way
that's different
from the way we treat lawyers or anybody
else
by recognizing that there is no need
to indicate any difference in how a
doctor should be treated let me you know
we all play a lot of different roles
sometimes sequentially
sometimes
simultaneously whether we're an advocate
a legislator an administrator an
adjudicator
um and we have to be careful always to
wear the appropriate hat in a particular
set of circles is one of my favorite
examples and those of you on the
committee will laugh is we sit here and
Conquer and we oppose the budget
um or we we sit here and we support the
budget or opposed it whatever but the
point is we pass the budget that has a
certain amount of money in it
and then we leave here and we go to our
counties where we act as the legislative
body in the county and we
shout obscenities at the legislators in
Concord who haven't given us enough
money for what we want to do in the
county we're the same people but we're
wearing different hats and we're looking
at it in different circumstances
and my point is that the issue here is
that we are not judges
we are not adjudicators we are
legislators now
there are many examples
of actions not being criminalized but
still being
subject to broader criminal penalties I
I mentioned to to the chair you're
driving along you spill your coffee
in the car
you reach over because you're going to
wipe up the coffee because you know it's
going to make a mess on the Upholstery
and when you do that you get into an
accident
there is nothing in the law
that says you should not be cleaning up
the coffee you spilled
but there is
a reckless driving law and you've
committed reckless driving and just
because it doesn't say in reckless
driving that that includes if you pick
if you clean up spilled coffee you're
still subject to that there's no law
against stealing jewelry
but there is law against stealing there
is nothing in the law that says clients
property is theirs and attorneys
shouldn't be stolen from it
um except that their theft statutes
statutes and more than that
they are the rules of professional
responsibility and so a lawyer who
decides to steal from his client
um
not only is subject to criminal law but
he's also subject to something that
might be much more serious to him or to
her
uh and that is in fact losing his
license being denied his right to to
earn a living
so an attorney violating these rules is
in real trouble the same thing is true
about a doctor a doctor who violates the
their rules the licensure all of the
things that are required of them
um is subject to the discipline
um within the medical community that
could cost him or her his license his
ability to function whatever and
um
and that already exists we do not need
something Superfluous to say and we also
want
um lawyers doctors to know that they
shouldn't do anything against the law
uh
I believe that
we are troubled by these bills because
we don't know exactly how to get from
where we are to where we want to go
we um had a split just a little bit ago
about asking
our citizens how they feel about this
issue and we'll have to see what happens
when that bill goes this bill is an
attempt to just undo something that
never should have been procedurally
in House Bill 2
understanding that
in its place will be other kinds of
limitation language for example the
language in 88 which keeps in place
those those penalties so I ask you to
overturn
um
or to not support the itl so that
another motion could be made
are there other people wish to speak yes
representative Macbeth thank you
I want to speak very briefly but I
really do feel doctors are in a
Physicians and Medical Care
Professionals are in a different place
they are making life and death decisions
all the time for us
those of us that have had Parents age we
know if they go through bypass surgery
some of our parents go through fine
others have strokes and and
complications and it wasn't the
physician's fault or the surgeon's fault
other of us have gone to the dentist and
you've had a tooth removed some of you
get dry Pockets some of you you know gum
surgery it repairs it's not it's not a
black and white issue medical personnel
make their best decisions based on what
they see at the time and I I want my
providers to give me care and to give
you care without the chilling effect of
thinking oh my God the record says the
woman's 40 24 weeks pregnant but we know
there's this gray area here or it does
or doesn't but I'll just say it does and
she's been in a traumatic car accident
and finally they've stabilized her and
now the Obstetricians come in and they
say God can we save the baby we know the
baby's heart's still beating the
mother's still alive but she's you know
her heart's going to crash any minute
and so guess what there's a lot of
different ways to do C-section do we rip
it open so that she never can have a
baby again but we save the baby because
the record says 24 weeks or do we go a
little bit longer take the C-section out
of the front hopefully the baby will
make it and the mother will make it and
the week and she can have children again
that decision I want my caretakers to
make without the chilling effect to
think oh you know what somebody's going
to sue me because it's 24 weeks and you
know what knowing guess how we decide
what knowing is you have to be in court
and decide what knowing is that's that's
for the triers of fact so it's not oh
yeah we know we know no you know because
you go to court and if anybody's been
sued personally for what they've tried
their best to do it's a horrible process
and we don't have enough health care
workers today in New Hampshire please
this is different Health Care is
different let's let the regulatory
boards sponsor I mean regulate our
Health Care Professionals and our
physicians like they're doing they've
been doing
um and and give me the right for
position to make a decision in the gray
area within their what they think is
best for me and my child and my family
and not what you all thought was best
other Comics representative
yeah just briefly it's a similar comment
to what I made when we were talking
about the Constitutional Amendment bill
um you know the healthcare industry
is a successfully self-regulating
industry
um the care that's provided is governed
by an oath that you take all the way
through to your licensing all the way
through to
um
the ethics boards and everything else
within the construct of of the care
that's delivered standards of care and
malpractice and other things the idea
of creating a uh law around something
that essentially we all know the
industry does not and would not allow to
take place and then to basically Place
heavy
criminal civil and licensure penalties
on that essentially non-existent
condition that was was legislated into
existence for the purpose of
I won't tell you what the purpose is
um you know seems to be a vast intrusion
into what I think we all agree is a good
way for medicine to operate which is
without the hand of the legislature
um involved and and
just adding the penalties on top of the
legislation makes it
um considerably more daunting and and
speaking to what representative Macbeth
said uh also also puts us as an outlier
as far as retracting qualified
Physicians
other uh yes representative Perez thank
you
I had every intention of keeping my
mouth shut through this but I can't I'm
sorry I worked in the healthcare
profession in the health care profession
for 42 years I trained at Mass General
in Boston I worked the emergency room I
worked the recovery room I worked
intensive care I worked Cardiac Care
we need this law doctors are not perfect
just like police are not perfect
I many times in my career
refused a doctor's order refused a
doctor's order because I knew it was not
in the best interest of the patient
refused I walked out I lost a job
because I walked out because you know
you're not allowed to speak up against a
doctor and doctors stick together
they are not perfect and this is a very
precarious situation when we are dealing
with the
abortions at 24 weeks at 50 I mean
Planned Parenthood doesn't do abortions
over 15 weeks
I would love to trust everybody who's in
every profession but we cannot the fetal
the fetus if you want to call it a fetus
I call it a child they need protection
too so I will
not a support passing this bill as a
42-year plus health care professional
who has seen it all
other comments yes representative
Staples
yeah
in terms of the quality of law
a law without enforcement or penalty
is like a bucket with a hole in it
like a country and western song says it
won't hold no beer
it's not serving a purpose
and worse than that
it's inadequate
bad legislation
and it would be better to actually
repeal the law instead of making it
such an inadequate inept structure
we profane the law when we do things
like that as much as we profane it when
we have conflicts in law
so
I've got to support the itl
um
and even though I'm pro-life and uh
and
don't like particular bills like like
this or like the one to repeal it
The Better Effort would be to repeal the
law instead of making it Hollow
although I won't support the repeal
either
yes representative cuta
so I know that there was talk about you
know just keeping the the punishments
for everybody equal and not having one
specifically for Physicians but I did
want to point out that in 2017 we had
amended RSA 630 colon 1 for first degree
murder to allow for the prosecution of
somebody who kills a fetus that could be
you know in a car accident or
intentionally however in that law we did
explicitly state that it would not
include an act performed by a physician
including the termination of a pregnancy
so
because that's precluded from the
existing statute to be able to prosecute
for
murder
we don't have an existing thing without
this we don't have any existing
penalties for knowingly terminating a
viable baby even if it was at 38 weeks
thank you other other comments yes
representative Manos
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
point out that the um the statute that
we're looking at says any health care
provider so this is not a statute that
that applies only specifically to
Physicians and doctors
it applies to any health care provider
the other thing I wanted to point out is
that it is correct as as you said Mr
chair that this applies to to knowing
Behavior or to a knowing act but it also
says or consciously disregards a
substantial risk that the fetus has a
gestational age of at least 24 weeks and
I think that's a very very uh slippery
precarious uh standard and it puts
health care providers in a position of
uncertainty in my in my view and
um
obviously the only point of a criminal
penalty is to either uh punish Behavior
or to discourage behavior and I think we
do not want to do that
um and so I strongly oppose the itl
motion I think this statute is Broad it
discourages Behavior it discourages
Health Care treatment from health care
providers that should be protected
other comments so I guess the only thing
I would say in response to
representative Manos to your point is I
it it seems to me that that um that
consciously disregards language and I
think I I if I recall correctly I think
I had some at least some role in the in
adding that language into it when the
criminal penalty statute was under
consideration basically that in there's
a well recognized Doctrine in the law of
willful blindness that basically says if
you you can't if if you are if you are
an actor
um you can't just close your eyes to
what is uh to what's right in front of
you and if you do do that then you can't
say well I didn't act knowingly because
I because I close my eyes I didn't know
I didn't know the light was red because
I closed my eyes you can't do that the
law says when you when that that that's
that concept of willful blindness and
that's what that's designed to capture
and I think it captures it entirely
appropriately the only other point that
I that I would make and I direct back to
the to the comments of uh the ranking
member I
I would agree with the ranking members
analysis when she gave the example of
the of the of the uh driver who reaches
down to pick up the coffee and is you
know and it can be Char if it turns out
that they're that constitutes criminal
negligence they could be charged
that that analysis would apply
if uh uh but uh if unlike what
representative cutoff correctly pointed
out
there there was a general statute that
applied
to and would make it murder or some
other kind of homicide to uh terminate a
fetus
but in fact there isn't in fact the fact
that there is a statute that makes it
murder if if a child is born alive is
the reason that later on when we get to
it I am I frankly I'm going to vote
against the born alive bill for that
very reason because it's not necessary
because if a fetus is if a child is now
born and the doctor acts uh doctor
effectively commits murder there's
already a penalty for that and in my
view there's no there is therefore no
reason for the born alive bill this is a
different situation when we uh when
you're talking about an abortion
um before the a child has been born so
um those those are my reasons for
supporting the itl and not wanting to
repeal the penalties anyone else uh wish
to speak
yes representative
um so by criminalizing doctors for doing
their job and working with the patients
to get the care they need by threatening
providers with a felony and imprisonment
the law as it stands is an invitation
for intimidation and harassment
by criminalizing providers it'll make it
very difficult for providers to come to
our state to give good care
and that is what's really important we
need providers we're down providers out
there and we need providers so we can't
hold people we'll say to criminalize
doctors they are in a different
um category and we do need to think
about that when we make our vote and I
am definitely against itl
are there anyone else wish to speak
right I guess we're ready for uh ready
for the roll call and the motion before
us is Ito
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip
YES Prep Grayson yes clerkata votes yes
rep Perez
rep Smith
rep hoorigan no rep dilorenzo no rep
Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no Brett Brennan no
rep lonza no rep Manos no
Rapture no chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
cheer yes do I have another yes Mr chair
I'd like to move
um that we retain two two four
is there a second
would you like to speak to your emotion
uh yes I I would
um
we generally know
I think we've seen begun to see a
pattern in these votes
oh yes
I've eaten is a supplement committee oh
he so he can't move that is correct
thank you um
uh
representative Macbeth seconds instead
thank you for good night
yeah can
and we
do retain before we've before an OTP
even almost
we can do a retain as the first motion
good okay all right okay go ahead
um uh before I continue I do want to say
that sitting in the audience are two of
our distinguished former members of this
committee who have come to see uh
representative we have three in the
audience oh oh and there I'm sorry three
that's right and I want to say that
they've come to see that we're carrying
on
um a good tradition
um I am I am I see a pattern and some of
you might also see the same pattern in
these votes
and I see that pattern because these are
really very difficult questions and
those of us who who feel strongly one
way or the other
most of us also see
that some of the arguments that are made
the positions taken by people who share
a different perspective are worthy of
thought they shouldn't just be dismissed
maybe at the end they should be I think
that over the next few months
we are very likely
to see in this state and in this country
new developments in this area having to
do with Reproductive Rights
and by retaining the bill now
um
it stays in our control and this is the
committee that could best make these
decisions and come the fall we might
find that any one of us
could suggest or all of us could suggest
something that does need
to be fine-tuned in in how the state
looks to its Reproductive Rights and by
retaining it we keep that option open
understanding that when the time comes
we can itl the bill and nothing happens
or we might use it in a vehicle that
might be helpful to any of us so my
suggestion is that we vote now to retain
and that gives us the opportunity to
move on to the next one thank you are
there anyone else wish to speak to the
motion retains yes representative
Staples
I would disagree
with that analysis
I would think that a retain might be
more useful applicable on a full repeal
of the fetal Life protection act rather
than a penalty section repeal as in 224
here
um
I think as I pointed out before that uh
taking the penalty out is
rendering it useless eviscerating the
purpose of the law
of the bucket with a hole in it again
it's got a hole in it now and it's going
to have a hole in it when it sits on the
retainer shelf and so I would be opposed
to retaining I think we should handle it
up or down here
anyone else wishes I have to offer an
apology to this committee
I
was on the wrong bill
and I can feel myself blushing so I know
that I am
and
um
and and what I would like to do is
withdraw my motion and
um hope that representative Macbeth who
was kind enough to
second
the motion would also withdraw the
second and I hope that you will all
accept my apologies and I know I'm the
only one who ever makes a mistake and so
you should be kind to me
there's no apologies necessary as you we
we all make mistakes Mr chair time so I
would just ask do you have since you've
withdrawn that motion and the second has
been withdrawn is that correct
representative Macbeth
so so do you have another emotion yes
and I hope it doesn't surprise you it
would be ought to pass is there a second
for that
representative Manos seconds all right
yes representative
I move that we apply all of
Representative Smith's arguments to any
future bill that she would like to apply
it to so that she doesn't have to say it
all over again
representative Alexander I would be very
pleased to do that as long as oh
representative Alexander pulled my
string
I I thank you very much and I will let
you know when I want that to happen
thank you do you wish to speak all right
so are we is anybody does anybody wish
to speak to what is now the the OTP
motion on this bill
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the roll on the motion now is OTP
Vice chair Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rap trap
no rep Grayson no clerkatab votes no rep
Perez
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes
yes rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes Brett
Brennan yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
reptiler yes chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
I will write the uh I was a report in
favor of itl who will write the report
in favor of OTP
that's me
all right all right
[Music]
no no no yes
um
all right
um you know what I since this is
probably the wrong since we're on the
subject of abortion related bills I
would propose to skip over 261 for the
moment and go to 2 271
and I would recognize representative
kutab for a motion
imove itl their second
son of kutaba do you wish to speak to
your motion
um I think we've already covered uh a
lot of the reasons I
yeah I think we've already covered it
I'll pass all right anyone else
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair and this is me speaking right now
um just for the record so
um
I for for one day I'm gonna claim myself
as the youngest member of this committee
um representative Kenny is not here so
at my young age
um
I haven't experienced quite as much but
what I do remember
very very
well is last year when the entire house
in a unanimous bipartisan way voted for
the fetal Life protection act as it
currently is right now
so now we're here in the fall again
and in this fetal Life protection act is
one of the mo it stops some of the most
extreme and unnecessary abortions that
happen
so in the unanimous and bipartisan
fashion we all voted to keep it in place
um so I believe this position fits the
majority of granite Staters it was a
hard-fought victory for 24 weeks I think
it's completely reasonable
um the complete repeal is unnecessary
and my hope is that the middle the
middle the the unanimous of the
committee will vote
um continue to hold the line in the
middle so thank you
all right anyone else wishes
thank you very much Mr chair
I am I feel great fondness
for the youngest member of the committee
who's present and I in fact think he is
wise Beyond his years
I also think that he is a very skilled
politician and that is something that I
am not I'm good on policy I'm good on
procedure but I am not good on politics
and I I make that clear I think that the
representative from Goffstown knows
that he might have been a little
disingenuous
in not pointing out that
highly inappropriately the fetal
protection act was inserted into house
bill to the trailer bill which is
supposed to include language only
related to expenditures in house bill
one there had never been a policy
Committee hearing there had never been a
policy committee vote it was dropped in
and the governor the distinguished
governor who I believe is going to fill
out his full term here before he goes on
to the White House
um the said publicly
that he really didn't like
this but and he is pro-choice he
reassures us but he had to vote for for
it because otherwise the budget wouldn't
pass
the governor forgetting that two years
before he had vetoed a budget and then
was able to get more in it that he
wanted so that to say that
overwhelmingly the house supported this
language not recognizing that it was
hidden in the middle of the of the state
budget is perhaps not telling the full
story
and my objection to this has always been
the policy
um and and the procedure and the
traditions of this house uh that
in theory does not permit extraneous
manners like this to be dropped in
household two unless there had been a
policy Committee hearing so I hope that
in that context
our youngest and Brilliant member would
acknowledge that the vote on the floor
was on the budget not particularly on
the
um
uh on the fetal Life protection act and
I would
hope that you would not support the itl
thank you anyone else wish to up uh
representative
so as we heard during the Committee
hearing there actually was a bill that
did go through the full process it was
house house bill 625 in 2021 and yes it
was then
later put into the budget but it
actually did get past the house and then
was laid on the table in the Senate
because it was added into the budget so
I just did want to clarify that it it it
did this
topic did have a full hearing thank you
other anyone else wish to speak I'm
sorry representative Alexander James
yeah thank you Mr chair just to uh help
clarify uh my friend representative
Smith who is um just as brilliant as me
um I would like to point out that last
year in 2022 we had a bill that came
through Judiciary that had to deal with
an ultrasound requirement and
um clarifying some language in that and
then that bill ended up passing the
house but that had the entire fetal Life
protection act and that bill was
supported by unanimous uh unanimously in
the house so this has been supported
before by in a bipartisan way
anyone else wish to speak to uh the
motion of itl on House Bill 271.
seeing none I think we're ready for a
vote
base chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander
yes
prep Andrews yes
rep testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rap
trap yes rep Grayson yes
clerkatab votes yes rep Perez
rep Smith
reporgan no rep dilorenzo no rep Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no rep Brennan no rep
Lanza no rep Manos no repturer no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
yes
um I would like to make a motion let me
take a deep breath on this to retain
this spill
and
um I would refer to a
to I would prefer to a comment that
representative Stapleton made earlier
that I thought made some sense and I
would respect representative Grayson's
View and therefore don't feel the need
to say anything else at all except that
I hope that you would agree to retain
this bill so that we could
um
keep open in this committee the
possibility of us taking any additional
action in this area if events determine
that that would be appropriate thank you
anyone else wish to speak yes
representative Staples
thank you Mr chair while I did say that
my opinion the better Bill to retain
under circumstances would be the 224
that was not to imply that I granted
approval to such a retained so I would
be opposed to that
anyone else wish to speak I guess one of
the things that I would and I very much
appreciate representative Smith's view
on this I respect her greatly
I I guess I I disagree with her for this
reason
I don't think that much is likely to
change between now and the fall
um I I think if it's much more likely if
things were to change it would be more
in the you know two years from after the
next election or beyond that
more importantly I'm
I
I had the opportunity to write an op-ed
piece several months ago about what was
going to happen after Roe v Wade and one
of the things I said there that I still
very much believe is
five years from now
maybe maybe it'll take a little bit
longer all of this stuff on both sides
is going to go away people are going to
be are going to come to the realization
that most people like the law about
where it is right now will they Tinker
with it a little bit should it be 22
weeks 20 on the one hand or 26 on the
other maybe you'll yeah maybe but
basically people are P it's going to
turn out that people are going to
realize that the politics on both sides
of this is going to settle out
people are going to realize that the
overwhelming majority of people do
support abortion rights but they want
limitations and that 24 weeks is about
where it should be and all of this is
kind of gonna go away and so I think
that to to prolong this
um is is not the best thing so I will be
I will be voting against uh the motion
to retain
anyone else wish to be hurt
all right
um all right so do we have a second
we'll representative oh I'm sorry do we
have a second on the retain motion by
representative Smith
representative page okay all right all
right so we're ready for a vote and I
would ask the court the court and ask
the clerk police to call the role the
general court the uh the motion before
us is to retain
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rap trap
no rep Grayson no clerkatab votes no rep
Perez no
rep Smith
rep Horgan yes
rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton yes Brett
page
Brett Macbeth yes rep Brennan yes
replanza yes Brett Manos YES Prep tour
yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails Ten to Ten
we have an another emotion
do we have to uh can we just submit it
with that yeah no we can yeah we can
submit it uh
we so so am I understanding correctly
then if we if we submit it without
recommendation
on on this state of the record there was
somebody would write a report in favor
of itl and somebody else would provide a
report
in favor of
retainers
all right so it would have to be someone
um
okay all right
so we so is it I mean is there a should
we have an O both of those have failed
should we have an OTP motion I mean I
don't I assume that would fail also but
if somebody I mean do we need I guess
what I'm really asking my my colleagues
on the on the other side is
do you in order to preserve your
position of if you want to try to
persuade the floor to vote OTP do you
need to have a motion here to do that I
don't know whether that what the answer
to that is
Scott Webster that I and I'm looking at
Kurt I don't think so because if we had
an itl motion on a bill
that's the other side
do you mean if it failed then somebody
could say we want to make another motion
of OTP no what I'm saying is if
in in ordinary circumstances the
committee voted itl
period the end new paragraph
the itl would be the committee position
and then the minority
could
say OTP even though that okay okay don't
you're right I agree with you this is a
little
dick that
um if you don't want a big Full House to
to die of indigestion
um we could reconsider the retention and
just one change we could retain the vote
and have one less vote to deal with on
the floor
um Mr chair I don't know if you'd be
interested in paying attention to the
view of the former Clerk of this
committee but representative Welker's
hand is up
yes of course representative Walker
please
foreign
second by representative page all right
anybody want to speak anybody think
there's anything else to say on this or
can we just call the roll all right so
the the the motion on the floor is ought
to pass
and I would ask the clerk to please uh
call the rule
no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rap trip
no prep Grayson no Clerk or tab votes no
repress no rep Smith
reporgan yes rep dilorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes rep page
Brett Macbeth yes Brett Brennan yes rep
Lanza yes Brett Manos yes repter yes
chairman Lynn no motion bails 10 to 10.
so uh representative can I ask you to
write the majority well I shouldn't say
can I ask you to write the important
support of itl and who will write
through a support and support of OTP
representative all right thank you
of
OTP all right
um
yes uh
all right
um yes so uh House Bill 346 and the
clerk recognizes representative cutoff
I make a motion to itl 346.
all right all right the motion's been
made and seconded uh representative you
wish to speak to your motion
so we heard a lot of testimony related
to the fact that if
families were delivering a baby that was
born with a known fatal fetal anomaly
that
they want to spend the time holding
their baby and their baby's only going
to live likely for you know a few hours
and they don't want their baby to be
whisked away off to a NICU to be
provided you know futile efforts such as
you know ventilator those types of those
types of things so it is my belief that
this bill the way it's written
has the potential to do harm to those
families
it is also my belief that where we
currently have
on the books the fetal Life protection
act it is illegal to abort a baby
post-viability so it wouldn't be
possible for a baby to be delivered that
way unless again it was in the the
context of
um
violating that provision
so
with that I think that the law is is
unnecessary that there's already
Protections in place for this and as
written I think it has the potential to
do to do more harm than good thank you
anyone else wish to speak to uh
HB 346 the itl motion yes uh
representative Lynn
um so this bill I feel is not
um an abortion bill it's actually a bill
that is for
people that go into early labor or they
have fetal fatal anomalies which
um we'll say you say does happen to
people and that
um and
when we heard testimony in the past one
thing I'd just like to bring up is I've
never seen anybody walk away from a a
baby who is passing away
everybody makes their best effort to
take care of both the mom and the baby
and so nobody ever turns awake here
anyone else wish to speak to HB 346 to
the itl motion I've seen none um I would
ask the clerk to call the roll please
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
okay
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton no
reptrip
yes
rep Grayson yes
clerkatab votes yes rep Perez
yes
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes
rep dilorenzo yes rep Eaton yes
rep page
Brett Macbeth yes
rep Brennan yes
rep Lanza yes rep Manos YES Prep tour
yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 18 to 1.
all right
yeah sorry
um so can this uh any reason this can't
go on consent
you're going consent okay anybody object
to that all right
um and uh representative could I ask you
to write the report
and uh representative Stapleton do you
will you be writing a Minority Report
oh it's going on consent I'm sure yeah
yeah okay all right that's fine
all right
[Music]
um
let me the next 62 turn to 562. Yes
uh and I would recognize uh
representative Stapleton for a motion
that's 562.
is there a second
I'll second all right motions be made
and seconded representative Stapleton do
you wish to speak to your motion
I believe that um
most
if not all
Physicians and medical people are bound
by ethical standards and
good practice
to provide their patients with
enough information for informed consent
on any number of medical
treatments or issues
um and I believe that um
this this law may be difficult to
administer and enforce
um
you have to dig pretty deep to determine
that there was a failure in
providing the proper if not adequate
conformed consent
so I think from a technical standpoint
um the bill is itl properly all right
anyone else wish to speak to uh
uh excuse me House Bill uh 562.
yes representative Perez
I am in favor of this bill and I had a
long conversation with
um the two people representing the um
clinics that perform abortions which by
the way they do not perform over 15
weeks after our
after we had testimony my concern is
that
very often people are not informed of
their options until they walk in the
door to have an abortion
so the example that I want to give to
you is that I am an 18 year old girl
about to graduate from college
and I find out I'm pregnant and I'm
gonna go to college and I want to have
an abortion I'm 18 so I can have it
without parental consent I am a wreck
about this I don't know what my options
are I am uninformed about my options and
I walk in to have an abortion
and you are now going to tell me well
you know you could have had give the
baby up for adoption there are places
that will help you
through your pregnancy and with the
delivery and help you with that
am I in the right frame of mind at that
point to get this information and it's
not just the 18 year old it's anyone
they're in an emotional state where are
they ready to accept and become informed
therefore I think it's just like we
don't have people sign their consent in
a hospital situation if they are have
received any medication well you know
emotion is a form of medication and I
really believe that we didn't have
anyone come really I don't believe and
testify about the options that were
available to people about that there are
places what happened to giving babies up
for adoption so therefore I think we
need to inform people we need to make
sure I asked when you call them back for
their appointment do you tell them
you know are you sure this is what you
want there are other resources available
for you well and are they provided by a
medical person I worked as a school
nurse for a very short time I had many
young girls and this is before you had
to be 18. you you had to notify your
parents I had many young girls come in
and you know they'd say I'd say well you
have options and I purposely put those
options in a bowl and had them choose
them one by one because if I said well
you can have an abortion they'd say oh
well she wants she thinks I should have
an abortion
I just think the options need to be
presented to people so that they can
make an informed rational decision about
the termination of a life prior to it
happening thank you
I'm sorry representative yes
representative greeson
thank you Mr chair during the testimony
on this bill we were told that
information regarding the reversal of
chemical abortions was dangerous medical
misinformation and that there is no body
of evidence to indicate reversible
reversal is possible
so the question is who determines that
something is medical misinformation
because we've been treated to a
smorgasbord of medical misinformation
over the last couple of years and the
federal government has been the Golden
Corral of it I looked at planned
parenthood's website to see what they
say about reversal of chemical abortions
and I cut and paste it here so this is
what Planned Parenthood says quote
here's the deal the abortion pill is the
popular name for a safe and effective
way to end an early pregnancy using a
combination of two medicines but
pepperstone and my soccer stall the
first medicine is a pepperstone is given
at a health care center or your health
care provider's office after taking
mepheprostone you take a second
medication misoprostol at home 6 to 48
hours later this causes cramping and
bleeding and empties your uterus claims
about treatments that reverse the
effects of medication abortion are out
there and a handful of States required
doctors and nurses to tell their
patients about them before they can
provide abortion care but these claims
haven't been proven in reliable medical
studies nor have they been tested for
safety Effectiveness or the likelihood
of side effects so experts like the
American College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists reject these untested
supposed
treatments studies on the abortion pill
do show that if you take the first
medicine but not the second the abortion
pill is less likely to work so if you've
begun the process of having an abortion
using the abortion pill but are having
second thoughts contact the doctor or
nurse you saw for the abortion right
away to talk about your best next steps
and what to expect close quote this
information is dated September of 2017.
as for there not being a body of
evidence to indicate reversal is
possible there actually is a body of
evidence small though it is so we'll
call it a fetus of evidence in 2018
physician George Delgado had a
peer-reviewed study published in the
medical journal issues in law and
Medicine where they studied 754 women
who all wanted to stop their in-progress
chemical abortions working with a an
obstetrician gynecologist married Dr
Mary Davenport and five other Scholars
Delgado demonstrated that when
administered within 72 hours of taking
mepheprostone the protocol has a 64 to
68 success rate in Saving unborn babies
notably the study also found zero
increased risk of birth defects or
pre-term births in fact the American
College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists the same American College
of Obstetricians gynecologist that
oppose the reversal process noted in
their publication practice bolison 225
merfeperson itself itself has not been
shown to cause cause birth defects
delgado's 2018 study was first publicly
available documentation on the protocol
since 2012 when he and Davenport
published an article following seven
women's progress in the annals of
pharmacotherapy
the problem is that the sample size was
very small
however it did show a tremendous success
rate and it also is consistent with a
European study that it showed similar
results although it too was very small
it should be noted that progesterone has
been used in pregnancies for over 70
years now safely and effectively so the
American Association of pro-life
Obstetricians and gynecologists support
the procedure and in their public
statement they make three important uh
statements about the procedure one
progesterone has been safely used during
pregnancy for decades without undesired
effects
when used properly for those infants who
survive from a pepperstone there is no
evidence of birth defects associated
with the medication and the American
Congress of of Obstetricians
gynecologist itself has research
confirming this
and the efficacy of reversal is in fact
higher than sitting and waiting alone to
see if a pregnancy continues so while
all that information regarding reversal
it does have the caveat that it is not
yet FDA approved so to say that there is
no body of evidence is not a true
statement it's just not a fully
developed body and it would require
further study but fewer women seem to
want to attempt that or they don't know
that that's an option that they could
potentially reverse it so my question
then is what is a Planned Parenthood
telling a woman who said calls up and
says I've taken the mepheper stone
but I I've changed my mind what do I do
now I'm calling that doctor or a nurse
who admitted it within the first couple
24 hours or so now what do I do what do
they tell that woman then sit and wait
and see what happens I hope for the best
we're in the abortion business not in
the abortion reversal business so I
don't I don't know what they tell them
but they do tell them that uh at home
medication abortion care is safer than
Tylenol now available without a clinic
visit and available by mail in just a
few days they also say medication
abortion is so safe that it could be
sold over the counter without a
prescription if not for political
considerations
they also tell a woman that it is
just like your monthly period
when you go to pass the fetus
but chemical abortions are done up to at
least 12 weeks and I I'm assuming they
told you 15 weeks but I know I heard 12
weeks
would say again
chemical Wars up to 15 weeks or 12 weeks
up to 11 weeks 11 weeks okay
and this is going to be something that
when you go when it clears your uterus
it's going to be just like your monthly
period
but I'm wondering if it might not be
just a little bit different because
usually your your monthly period is just
going to be an unfertilized egg and some
other little tissues that are attached
to it I'm thinking that an 11 week old
fetus might have a little bit more of a
resemblance to a baby
the last thing that concerns me is that
there is a direct link between human
trafficking and abortions and with the
increased frequency of chemical
abortions and and how more readily
available the medications are that this
would help to feed the human trafficking
uh because it covers the tracks of the
perpetrators so are these women while
there is a a an inquiry as to whether or
not a woman is pressured into having an
abortion I wonder if it doesn't go far
enough as to say this could be the
result of a rape during human
trafficking is there even a a poster
that says here's the national human
trafficking hotline or something along
those lines because this is too easy to
to cover the tracks of those misdeeds
I I I'm liking informed consent
I think the more you know the better
your decisions are
and while it may not be FDA approved
maybe you get to be that 755th trial for
Dr Delgado
so I will oppose the ideal move
right other
um you then
thank you I know okay I will vote
against it all right that's no that's
fine uh
what I just went yeah yes representative
Lantern all right then I'll get to you
guys in just a second so um I have
worked at a community Health Center uh
it's a perinatal case manager there for
many years and I so everybody who came
through my doors
um were found pregnant they had a
pregnancy test
um and then I sat down with them and I
asked them what are I gave them Options
Counseling so the first thing I would
ask them is if they were looking to
continue their pregnancy and get them
right into care if not what um there are
other options were to place their baby
up for adoption
and I would I can't tell you if I had 10
girls
I wouldn't even have one sometimes that
would offer that and I'm an adoptive
child okay so I believe in that as well
but at the same time I think we need to
keep in mind
um that we need to make sure that women
have access to all their options and
need to be made aware of all of their
options I know I provided good
um you know Options Counseling I then
sent them if they did want to find out
about having a termination I would then
send them to Planned Parenthood and who
would go further on and help them with
that but I I know that there are people
out there that do provide Options
Counseling for a woman it's um people
are not just sent away and told
otherwise so I know that I sat with each
individual female and gave them that
information and stuff so thank you uh
representative tur and then
representative Stapleton representative
and thank you Mr chairman
um I just wanted to mention a couple of
things related to this I think the most
important one being
um informed consent uh is not given uh
to avoid legal consequences informed
consent is given to uh adhere to the
standard of care to make sure that the
patients are aware of their treatment
and aware of their options it's given to
avoid medical liability
um if anything goes wrong there's a
usually a multitude of
of uh options and consequences related
to any store to care including this type
of care so that was the first uh I think
overriding thought here is that we are
once again stepping into an area where
a self-regulating medical profession is
already well taken care of this issue
and this bill goes further to actually
prescribe what types of information have
to be included in informed consent
that's not done elsewhere and I think
for a good good reason
um
I also want to point out that um
the executive director of the loving
Center in terms of whether women are
offered other options pointed out during
her testimony that the first line of
their informed consent goes through
options other than abortion and that has
to be signed by every patient following
an hour of consultation
regarding the procedure so I do think
this is being done I do think people are
being being offered their options and
the other thing and I will apologize uh
I took this in notes and never looked
into the actual study but it was pointed
out to us that Acog
doesn't support the reversal of
medication abortion as a as a a
legitimate course of care the other
um actions that I think were cited
relate to other instances where this
drug is used and you're found to be
pregnant I think I do not know I do not
have the study but it was mentioned to
us that a clinical trial exploring the
concept of reversing medication
abortions was halted you know if you all
remember that testimony during during
our hearing so I I would support the
ideal motion representative Stapleton
upon listening to the testimony here
and I just reviewed the testimony in my
notes when we had the hearing on this
I've had a change of mind and I would
like to withdraw my itl motion
and as representative would you like to
withdraw your second all right so the
question then is um is there a do we
have a motion on the floor
um is there a motion Mr chair I move we
ought to pass house bill 562.
all right is there a second all right
Motion in a second anybody wish to speak
to it
Gleason Gleason
uh uh actually greeson moved and um
Perez second
yes please
the other the other
talk I had with Planned Parenthood is
because I was not I'm not up to date on
taking these pills I did intensive care
so one of my concerns was again I used
the 18 year old and um I said I'm an 18
year old girl I'm about to graduate from
high school I'm going to college I'm
pregnant I want I don't want to go to
the abortion clinic I don't want
somebody to see me can I take these
pills
how do you know
I am under 11 weeks pregnant well I
asked you when your last period was I
said well I'm 18 years old I'm scared to
death I know I'm at least 12 or 13 weeks
I'm gonna lie
how do you and it's my understanding you
could actually die from these pills if
you have them over a period of time over
a certain gestation she said well you
can have an ultrasound I said I'm 18
years old I'm not going to subject
myself to an ultrasound and have you
find out I need to have this abortion I
need to go to college
so
are you going to tell me when I walk in
to get my first pill that you know you
know if you're over 11 weeks you really
could die you really could die
I need to know that I need to know
what's going on before I'm there
anyone representative top
the way that the bill is currently
written has medical information that is
known to be false
and I do not believe that we'd be acting
in good faith to require a position
legally to obligate them to give
patients information that they know
is inaccurate so for that reason I will
not be submorting
the OTP motion anyone else wish to be
heard on this
yes representative Staples
and part of this to explain why I had a
change of mind
to withdraw my motion
informed consent there's got to be
specific to the procedure involved
and
when we're talking about abortion that's
a special
aspect
of clinical operation
and it should be
replete with
complete spectrum of all possibilities
and especially to guard against the Bad
actors
the people who would not observe best
practices Medical
professionalism or even the law
so
I believe we need to
put the statement out there in law that
this is a special
situation and like other medical
procedures that are special that need to
inform consent that's tailored to that
including options which I think is part
of informed consent anyways
for a patient to make a valid decision
um but I I do here and we do know that
there are
improper practices out there Bad actors
even if the majority of providers in
abortions are observing the law and
would so do
by conscience
um
as my on my other life I'm a pro-life
sidewalk
Advocate and in in a group known as
Upper Valley Pray For Life
and we would have a prayerful respectful
lawful presence outside of abortion
clinics
to offer help advice alternatives
as well as prayers for people going in
there and having the abortions as well
as those deciding not to have abortions
because a woman that has abortion has
got a heavy load to bear
and they need support and prayer as well
but I saw many coming out of
abortion clinics in in a sorrowful
tearful
hurtful mode
after
reality sets in and they see what
they've done counter to maybe their
family values or their religious values
or their ethical values and so I have to
ask the question were they given proper
informed consent relative to options and
alternatives
well that's why I had to withdraw my
motion and in favor of the OTP anyone
else wish to speak on the representative
Oregon
um thank you um I mean I feel uh
yeah I feel uncomfortable with forcing
uh the well they're talking about the
adoption that does involve the uh
the woman
um you know burying the baby for nine
months and that's uh a life-altering uh
experience in and of itself even if you
have the baby up for adoption I don't
and um they these adoption agencies this
doesn't address the issue of a
licensing the adoption agencies it does
say um it I mean it does say there's
supposed to be a geographically indexed
materials but there's no detail on like
how do you know which adoption agencies
are
you know can be trusted in which can't
so there doesn't seem anything to
address like licensing or supervision of
those and there's certainly a ample ways
that could be uh that could be abused
and it also uh
and like I said vaguely refers to uh
services available
upon Chopper while the child is
dependent but this bill doesn't do
anything about uh programs to help
young women who are raising babies
either by themselves or with the help of
a
you know equally equally young partner
and there are some excellent programs in
New Hampshire that deal with that but
this bill does nothing for it it doesn't
prodify to any
funding for the adoption agencies or the
or the uh you know the agencies to help
help young women raise their uh raise
their babies and also um we could we
hear a lot about unfunded mandates here
if we um this bill provides you know
provides no provides no funding even
though the fiscal note clearly says
there's a very significant cost involved
so I think it's a
and uh so I just think this bill is uh
unnecessary and counterproductive so
I mean
thank you Mr chair
it should be pointed out that the bill
clearly states that all references to
the reversal of a chemical abortion the
procedure is not yet FDA approved that
does not mean it is dangerous medical
misinformation the procedure is just not
FDA approved so either way the woman is
not going to get complete accurate 100
percent medical information one way or
the other either it is either the you
have to tell her it is impossible to
reverse it or that it is possible to
reverse it which one is it
when they themselves say there's just no
body of evidence to say it
so it's not dangerous medical
misinformation it's just not FDA
approved
any other comments
well yes representative
I just want to say too I think it's Phil
um this bill though is filled with some
misinformation and that we need to think
about you know
um that women do understand about their
bodies their own bodies and wish as New
Hampshire legislators should not make
that decision for them
anyone else wish to come yes
representative thank you Mr chair I
wanted to just say
um uh respond to uh representative
catawb and completely support what she
said that we can't in good faith be uh
dictating and putting into a statute
medical misinformation
um and so I strongly oppose the of the
OTP anyone else wish to be hurt yes
representative De Lorenzo thank you um
for taking my question or comment
um you know I think that
18 year old woman are adults
I think that
young people are very well educated
today they have access to the internet
and they have Circles of friends
allergy teachers and
they certainly have access to the
information that's out there about
making decisions
thank you
anyone else any other comments so I
guess I would say just my comment I um I
am I cannot support the OTP Motion in
this um I certainly agree
that there should be informed consent
but I candidly
if you look at this at what this bill
requires it's not this goes beyond
informed consent it's really sort of
designed to in to kind of intimidate
let's that's my view intimidate a woman
into not having an abortion and I think
that goes too far
and I really also think and and I'm not
someone who you know who who finds
things offensive very easily but if I
were a woman I would find this form
Verity demeaning along for basically for
the reasons that representative De
Lorenzo said that it it really sort of
um
cast The View that you know an adult
woman is is someone that really needs to
you know needs the protection of a man I
suppose that's the theory or of somebody
else other than the woman herself
because she's not capable of uh of
making an informed decision even when it
may be a very hard decision I don't
think that that's true I think that 18
year old women you know could there be
some cases of of there being coercedure
I don't doubt that but
um this this just this this bill it
seems to be just goes too far so I I
cannot support the OTP on this anyone
else uh wish wish to be heard
all right I think we're ready for revoke
and the motion before us is OTP uh
um house bill 562.
chairman Wallace no rep Alexander no rep
Andrews
rep testerman no rep Stapleton YES Prep
trip no
rep Grayson yes
Clerk or tab votes no rep Perez
rep Smith
rap Horrigan
uh no
rep dilorenzo no rep Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no rep Brennan no
rap lonza no rep Manos no
Rapture no
chairman Lynn
motion fails 3 to 17.
I make a motion to itl house bill 562.
representative is anything more you I
think we've all had our we've all spoken
a lot about this but if there's anything
more you wish to say please
I think I've made my points thank you
all right anyone else wish to speak on
the itl motion on House Bill 562.
seeing none I guess we're ready for the
vote
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton no rap trap yes rap
greeson no
clerkatab votes yes rep Perez
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes yes rep page
Brett Macbeth yes rep Brennan yes rep
blanza yes
rep Manos yes repturer yes chairman Lynn
yes
motion passes 17-3
um
so uh
who would like to write the majority
report in support of itl
do I have any volunteers
representative lanzer will you write the
majority
do it all right um so let me just make a
note of that uh
Let's uh maturity
and who uh will there be a Minority
Report
no Minority Report
um
all right well all right Stapleton
or the minority all right
all right um objection to consent is
there
can we do with three with three
Seventeen three vote can we do it
no one two is I really stretch yeah okay
so yeah all right so now it'll go it'll
it'll go on the regular account
all right next I'm going to turn to uh
House Bill 591
um
prohibiting abortions after detection of
fetal heartbeat and I rep I recognize uh
representative cutoff for a motion
I make a motion to itl
for a second
I can do it
I'm sorry who was that
representative Alexander okay all right
uh representative Tom if you'd like to
speak to your motion
so I'm here to represent how the
majority of my constituents feel and I
think it's been made very clear that the
majority
feel that there should be an option for
women to have the Liberty to make these
decisions with their health care
providers and this is a near total
abortion ban which is just
by far polling data has shown that it's
a slim number of people
that support that and that the vast
majority do not so especially given the
idea that I know I personally when I was
pregnant with my daughter her her fetal
heartbeat was shown on ultrasound at
five weeks six days
that's often times before somebody even
knows that they're pregnant so
I think we need to to you know
keep that into consideration so thank
you
anyone else wish to speak to the itl
motion on House Bill 591. yeah this was
was my bill this was put in
there was a lot of argument when they
put the
bill that finally passed 24 weeks in
about should we have a
a
ultrasound or what should we have there
are all sorts of arguments
I put this in not because
I thought it was right because I would
put zero weeks as a cut off
but yeah but because it was one it was
really relatively simple
a uh a a almost any doctor
with this stethoscope you can determine
if there's a heartbeat period end of
story uh and if you can't make a
decision at that point it's just hard
for me to believe so I'll vote for this
even though I know it makes the number
of weeks five or six maybe ten uh yeah
but but it's it's a simple solution and
it's you know it pretty much does the
job
all right anyone else wish to speak to
uh House Bill 591 representative Greece
thank you Mr chair one of the arguments
in support of abortions is that the baby
is not viable outside the womb before
some number of weeks 24 weeks for
example and therefore abortions should
be unrestricted but that misses the
whole point the baby is not intended to
survive outside the womb before 24 weeks
in fact the baby's not intended to be
viable outside the womb before nine
months that's why they're called
premature babies nine months is the
normal gestation period for a human baby
thank God you're not an elephant because
it's two years
the fact that a baby can survive being
born before full development is simply a
miracle and medical advancements have
made survival at younger ages much more
realistic but none of these is easy or
ideal
philosophically I agree with
representative testerman
five weeks is
goes beyond what I believe
philosophically unfortunately
I also agree with representative cutoff
we're just not there
I like the idea of leaving the fetal
Life protection act alone I don't think
we're going to advance the front any
farther I think it becomes a heart issue
at that point and it's not a polit it's
not a it's not a simple solution
whatsoever I just don't I I agree with
the principle of uh of the feedlife or
excuse me of the uh
the fetal heartbeat bill but I'm afraid
that we're just not in a place right now
where that's going to pass and I would
have I want to support the itl now
because I actually agree with uh or
disagree with its tenants but I just
don't think we're there
thank you representative uh anyone else
wish to speak yes representative tur
yeah just just one quick what I hope to
be factual correction
um a stethoscope cannot as far as I
understand detect a heartbeat at um
at the a six-week level uh there's no
there's no pumping action taking place
it's just uh cells twitching so you'd
need an ultrasound
anyone else uh representative Perez
although I support this bill 100 because
of being a nurse you did not pronounce
someone dead
until their heart stopped not when they
were brain dead but they were not
pronounced dead until their heart
stopped so I and My Heart of Heart
believes that life begins its perception
conception I do not think we are at this
point as well I don't think we can and I
would love to see the 24 weeks come down
because what babies are viable younger
than that now and that's one of the
reasons why I'm against any type of
um
written in stone that we can't change
that so
um I will vote for it
um because it I and but I do know my
constituents do want to have the
protection of the present fetal heart
fetal protection act thank you anyone
else wish to yes representative
Stapleton
I was the author of uh HB 629 the
viability bill that I wrote on the basis
of Planned Parenthood versus casing
and I thought that that would be a
middle ground
even though that I'm a pro-life guy that
believes that life is sacred from the
moment of conception to the moment of
natural death
I understand that this is not the Bible
Belt and there's no way that this bill
is going to probably make it in the
house or the Senate remember the
governor
however as a matter of personal belief
and morality
I have to vote for the bill because
every life is sacred from the moment of
conception that's what I believe
subscribe to and I can't counter that
with a vote against it I will vote OTP
by any anyone else wish to speak on HB
all right the motion before us now is
itl and I would ask the clerk to call
the roll please Vice chairman Wallace
yes rep Alexander yes rep Andrews no
rep testerman no rep Stapleton no
reptrip yes
rep Grayson yes
clerker tab votes yes rep Perez no
rep Smith yes
rep Horgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes
YES Prep page
right Macbeth yes rep Brennan yes rap
Lanza yes rep Manos yes ripped her yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 16-4
um representative
would you write the majority report and
who will there be a Minority Report and
if so who will write it
sounds like there will not be a Minority
Report or
all right
um
all right I think we are through that
difficult topic
um so let's turn
to something which
sounds like it's going to be from what
from the hearing this morning there will
be equally uh an equally difficult topic
but maybe
oh two I'm sorry great yes
yes
all right um so let me turn to how it's
Bill 261 authorizing residential tenants
to terminate their lease and instances
of domestic violence
or following a disabling illness or
accident the chair recognized
representative Alexander for a motion um
thank you Mr chair I feel like we moved
from one difficult topic to another when
you're talking about housing
um I I will move um and expedient to
legislate on HP 261. all right is there
a second
a planet Stapleton
all right so there's been moved and
seconded and representative Alexander do
you wish to speak to your motion yeah I
mean briefly um this is just another one
of those bills that I feel like puts
more infringement on
um the rights of landlords
um we all know that the housing crisis
is a supply side issue so more
regulation is going to exacerbate the
problem I will say that it although I
feel for victims of domestic violence
um it's really not an issue of a
landlord's issue the landlord's only
issue is the property and maintaining
the property for the tenants so my
concern with this bill is that the onus
of who holds the bag at the end of the
day goes to the landlord when it's not
really in the landlord's biggest
landlord's issue um
I also don't see it happening as
frequent enough I don't think that there
were a lot of examples that we heard or
if any at the public hearing that this
bill was absolutely necessary and then
um I know there's a couple amendments
floating around I I personally like
don't think that any of those amendments
will make me get to a yes on this bill
um and then I just
I had something else but I'm gonna leave
it at that
yes uh representative Greece thank you
Mr chair
uh attempting to work with a sponsor of
this bill in crafting an amendment that
might be able to uh bring representative
Alexander to a yes uh and and failing to
come up with said Amendment uh that even
I could continue to say yes to I'm
afraid that we just can't get to a point
where we're not sandbagging the
landlords that said I did speak with a
couple of the landlords that testified
and told them that they would it would
behoove them uh be very beneficial for
all all parties if they would be
active in
um identifying areas where landlords can
uh take some action or work with
legislators to to be able to address
these issues that come up and they were
certainly positive to taking a more
proactive position working with tenants
associations working with the landlords
working with legislators so this bill is
not going to get it none of the
amendments are going to get where we
need to go so I'm I I will support the
itl motion just because we couldn't come
up with a with a solution all right
anyone else wish to speak to House Bill
261 yes representative thank you Mr
chair um I wanted to ask representative
Alexander if he would consider
withdrawing his motion and doing a
retain on this I know that there's the
commission that you're involved in with
landlord and you know tenant issues and
you know if we
take it to the floor these may be
options that can't be considered by that
so would it retain be something you and
I appreciate the concern and there were
there were actually a lot of there are
some bills that have hit the floor that
I have been interested in looking at
that I wouldn't like to see itl but this
is one of these issues that the
committee isn't looking at further
regulation we're looking at more at the
supply side issue and if you look um
back at the public hearing and the
testimony that we got from some of the
stakeholders in the housing and it's
it's the whole Gambit right we're
bringing in everybody else
um we're really trying to steer the
conversation not in a regulation
perspective so
um I don't see anything in this bill
that you know I mean correct I'm one of
10 people on the committee but there's
also multiple people in this room that
are on the committee and I personally
don't see anything in this bill that the
special committee could look into and
possibly solve so
um it's a good it's a good guess but a
question but no I don't see it all right
anyone else wish to speak to uh House
Bill 261
but the motion on the floor is uh in
expedient to legislate and I'd ask the
clerk to call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
oh
rep Stapleton
yes
rep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
or qatab votes yes rep Perez
rep Smith no
rep Horrigan no rep Delorenzo no rep
Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth oh Brett Brennan no rap
lonza no we're at Manos no rapture
chairman Lynn
I'm going to vote no uh because so that
I remain in the majority to move to vote
for a motion for reconsideration
um so I'll just tell you that right up
right up front so I
oh you don't oh I'm sure well thank you
thank you for that then yes and change
that to a yes please
ah
okay so the motion fails nine to ten
so
now
I would like to move for reconsideration
no all right so
um and I don't I I guess I'll I mean I
just I guess I'd just be completely
there's nothing more to say than I think
that the reason the motion the reason
the motion passed is we didn't have the
full committee here we now do have the
full committee here and so I'm uh I move
for reconsideration I don't have
anything else to say can we do it by
hand voter
I think we probably ought to have a
rollercoaster you need a second on that
yes could I have a second
a while a second okay all right
so uh all right so we're back to
um
uh
you want to follow the rules yeah would
you please
this is on uh so for the motion of
reconsider uh for House Bill 261 Vice
chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes reptrick yes rep Grayson
yes Clerk of tab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith yes
reporgan
rep De Lorenzo yes rep Eaton rep page
Brett Macbeth yes rep Brennan yes rep
Lanza yes rep Manos yes repturer yes
chairman Lynn
yes
motion passes unanimously
Mr chair yeah I would like to explain my
vote
um I believe very firmly that in a small
D Democratic Society in a legislative
body everyone who wears appropriate to
play a role should be able to play a
role and while I disagree
um with at least some of my colleagues
on how I want this bill to end up I
would never vote in any way to deny one
of my colleagues the possibility to vote
in his own right thank you well thank
you uh very much representative Smith I
very much appreciate your your uh
position on that uh
all right so
um
so the mo so we've reconsidered
um and so now
um the floor's open the floor is open so
do I have a uh representative Alexander
do you move to uh itl yeah can uh Mr
chair can I move in expedient to
legislate please yes is there a second
second all right any further discussion
all right can I asked the clerk please
to call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes
rep Stapleton yes reptrip
yes rep Grayson yes clerkatab votes yes
rep Perez yes
rep Smith rep Oregon no rep dilorenzo no
rep Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth no
rep Brennan no rep Lanza no rep Manos no
reptier no chairman Lynn yes motion
fails 10 to 10.
another emotion
for you know for this could for the same
reason that that was mentioned by the
former colleague I guess I I leave it up
to my colleagues on the other side but
if if you don't have an OTP does that
present a problem for you I leave it to
you Mr chairman can offer a motion to
retain
this spill
I'm sure yes you certainly can offer a
motion to retain okay there there were
two amendments
um the the person who uh
uh coordinated those is out ill
um haven't had a full chance to debrief
um I think there were honest efforts put
forward I don't know that the remaining
issues are are on
um
irreconcilable
that's right
a second so may I ask a question
um representative yes because I mean
this would have a
along the lines of what representative
Alexander suggested
I had I had suggested an amendment which
I'm I'm not sure how if it actually I
think I circulated it at least to my car
because I'm not sure I circulated to
everybody I I may have though basically
it it my proposed amendment would have
done nothing with regard to the landlord
tenant law but it would have said that
it would have added a provision to RSA
173b the domestic violence statute
saying in the damages section that one
of the things that a victim of domestic
violence could recover from the abuser
was any costs incurred by that victim as
a result of of breaking a lease
um in the way and the purpose of that
basically along the lines of what
representative Alexander said my basic
problem with this whole bill is trying
to when the where the landlord is not at
fault putting some owners on the
landlord my amendment was designed to
say the onus belongs on the abuser and
and you know so I I guess what I'm
I'm just kind of wondering if and I
really throw it out to
everyone on the committee just
are any of you sort of receptive to the
idea that that might be an appropriate
Amendment
um because I
I if it is then you know then that's
something I'm I I at least would
speaking of myself would be willing to
talk about but if it's if it's just
another
you know if you're just thinking that
we'll have another amendment that will
sort of talk about
what can we do the landlords I I would
not be receptive to that person okay oh
sorry
I think uh thank you very much for
raising that there are I know at least
two other amendments that have been
prepared
um with names of members of the
committee and I think this might be a
good example of a bill that could um
be improved by this committee and end up
with something that balances the
competing needs I mean I truthfully had
problems with the combination of uh
domestic violence on the one hand and
then
um
uh
uh that yeah the disability on the other
I thought it was it was conflating two
very very different issues and very
different
um effects and responsibilities of the
landlord I think the point that you've
just raised is a very interesting one
one of the problems we always have with
these landlord tenants is always it's
either or it's either for the landlord
or for the tenant and it's in the
landlord's best interest to keep his
property or her property full and have
tenants who were paying and it's the
tenant's best interest to have decent
housing and why we can't
thread the needle
so everybody benefits I'm not sure but
this might be a good example of one
where we could improve the bill and I
would certainly
like to see your Amendment
and I'll I'll just say since I made the
motion
um you know I think there's many many
competing forces in this in this this
bill in terms of goals some to protect
the the
um anonymity and whereabouts of a
domestic violence fism sum is to provide
resources for them to move or free them
from joint tenant leases and other
things and then there's the whole
disability portion which I agree is
quite separate that was my reason and I
and I I think your your point is also
well within the realm of what should be
considered so can I can I may I just ask
Alex representative Alexander then I
want to definitely want to hear from you
representative but representative
Alexander if we were to retain this can
you give us some
sense of what what if any effect you
think it would or would not have on the
work that you and your committee is
doing
um thank you Mr chair where we are
specifically looking at loosening
regulations around the housing crisis
allowing you know maybe more dense
density things like that we're not
looking at like landlord-tenant issues
so it would have no effect I will say
again though that even if we retain it I
don't see a final product that I could
probably support
um and you know I actually agree with
believe it or not I agree with
representative Smith and I have a
problem with the disability and domestic
violence in the same bill and all that
stuff and I just don't think it's
something that the committee
could work on to get me to a yes so all
right representative Delorenzo
sorry I was wondering if um your
amendment has anything to do with the
victim Witness Protection Program
it it does not it just it is simply it's
simply an addition to the damages
section of the domestic violence thing
in other words a currently domestic
violence thing says you can get damages
for this that and the other thing and
this would say this that and the other
thing and damages for you know loss of
uh for for having to break a lease or
something like that
um all right anyone else wish to be
heard on the motion to retain yes
representative
the um
the abuser
is the abuser a husband
a live-in partner
or remote uh boyfriend or a stalker even
um in trying to transfer
the onus away from the landlord who's
not responsible for the domestic abuse
to another party
and this bill I would almost think that
that's not your main to the for the
intent of the bill
and the best of the reach you may be
right you may you may be right I mean I
didn't I did I had not I have not
submitted the Amendments and so you know
the clerk hasn't looked at it you may be
right the clerk might say this is not
Jermaine and he can't
so on that I I would I would be opposed
to the retain
anyone else wish to be heard on the
motion to retain I really want to get
out of here talk but I'm going to I
would support that type of amendment
because I I see the goal of the bill
wasn't it was to protect the domestic
violence victim so I don't know that the
source was really you know I mean I
think that's the type of you know good
type of thought you know thought process
or you know putting two heads together
so that might then be able to separate
the issues regarding disability and
other I don't know I I support it and I
I think it'd be worth looking into all
right anyone else wish to be heard on
the motion to retake
all right so I
I guess my
as much as I would hope that's at some
point in the future and maybe next time
particularly if and you may be very well
maybe right representative Turner that
that the amendment I propose would would
if the speaker had to rule on it would
rule was not germane to this that might
very well
I'm sorry rapid Stapleton that might
very well be correct
um so I think I think in the end
although I appreciate very much what
everyone has said in support of
retention I think I probably would come
down against uh retaining the bill
um so and with that anyone else have
anything to to say all right so the
motion before us is a motion to retain
and I would ask the clerk to call the
rule
[Music]
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no
rap trap no rep Grayson no
clerkatab votes no rep Perez no
rep Smith yes
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes
yes rep page yes Brett Macbeth yes rep
Brennan yes rep lonza yes rep Vanos YES
Prep tour yes
chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
so
they're in motion
don't not seeing one all right so
um I um
representative Alexander will you write
the report in support of itl I would be
happy to thank you and um
guess there isn't really any report in
support of retain so uh if somebody on
the floor is going to move to OTP if
they'll do that on the floor I guess
um well yes I'm representative Manos I I
am wondering if we we can go back and I
can offer the the motion of OTP so we
have it on the record you certainly may
so you move OTP is there a second
second by representative tur do we need
to have uh any discussion or can we just
call the Roll All right so the motion
now before us is OTP
and um I would ask the clerk to please
call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no prep Stapleton no rap trip
no rep Grayson no clerker tab votes no
rep Perez
rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes reply
Lorenzo yes rep Eden YES Prep page yes
Brett Macbeth yes Brett Brennan yes rep
Lanza yes rep Manos yes repter yes
chairman Lynn no
motion veils 10 to 10
. so uh representative Manos would you
like to write the report on OTP
all right
that only took five though
I think so yeah
all right now 5 33. all right now uh 5
333 and I'm going to uh
oh yeah you know what how about five
minute break does that sound does that
sound like everybody could use that we
only have two to go so
do it
well this if this might this might take
a little this will take a little while
I'm afraid
okay
good grief
tonight
hang in there oh yeah
thank you
okay
oh no I meant in terms yes
emails on legislative email to council
they're doing them in Mass from
individuals but they're rapid fire one
after another
in batches
okay
um
what's up
foreign
okay
thank you so much yeah
um surprise you if I did because I knew
I was confident and then Paul mentioned
he sent me a message
foreign
thank you
which one which one did we have
representative luanza writing the report
on
um
oh uh
that was on hi having fun
oh well yeah John just didn't know
good morning
[Music]
abortion bills together
doesn't want to write the majority
report in support of itl on the informed
consent would you mind writing it to 562
oh
all right
um we're back in session I'm going to
take up House Bill 652 next and I would
recognize representative Wallace for a
motion
I would move to retain house bill
652 FN is there a second
all right moved by representative
Wallace seconded by representative Smith
representative Wallace would you like to
speak to your motion
uh we'll I'll very briefly I move to
retain this there is some merits to this
bill that we uh certainly can fix over
the summer so that's the intention we'll
address this over the summer and improve
it for the fall right anybody else wish
to speak yes representative Perez yes I
was given information about this by the
representative that put the bill forward
that actually in the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts they do have a law
that supports the one that we're trying
to get and she has the full law I just
printed out I think I printed out on all
of it but
um
so you know there is precedence for this
type of the thing
anyone else wish to speak to
representative uh Horrigan please
um thank you very much we uh of course
we're being asked to legislate by
anecdote because of one experience she
and a library trustee in their Town
ahead and turned out not to go into to
make details about it but the uh
controversy in question was actually a
meeting that probably both the library's
trustee and the person the people the
library trustee were concerned about
both could have had their probably some
extent did have their reputations
um
adversely affected by what's going on so
the example of the given white this bill
is needed was uh
didn't somewhat uh didn't quite mean the
same thing to me as it did as it did to
the uh the prime sponsor but there may
be but certainly there may be something
we need to talk about in the summer so
they're
we probably have stumbled onto a topic
of interest and something
maybe should be done next year or
something all right anyone else wish to
uh representative Alexander um thank you
Mr chair this is something I'm very
interested in working on this summer so
I hope that we can do that very
important to a constituent in town thank
you no I I agree I think that they're
they're my my initial reaction at the
beginning of the hearing what was I was
very negative as you probably may have
seen from my questions as I heard more I
began to kind of come around and think
that well maybe there is something that
can be done here I think one of the one
of the things that needs to be addressed
is the is the scope of it right now in
other words the the thing that really
sort of concerns me is I I as I was
talking to representative Smith about
this what we were kind of kicking it
around and one of the things that
occurred to me is you know suppose I was
trying to think of an example and I I'm
not sure I have a better one than I gave
her which I think she didn't think was
very good and she probably she was
probably right
but you know suppose that I suppose the
situation is this the there's a uh at a
town meeting somebody proposes to put on
the ballot uh resolution condemning
Vladimir Putin and the Selectmen have
one or have want to have a meeting to
decide whether this is something that
really appropriately goes on the ballot
or not do and there may they may be
saying some bad things about Vladimir
Putin do they have to send him notice
that he has somebody has to be there I
would I would assume we might say well
that might go a little too far but yet
under the language of uh of the proposed
bill
um arguably you'd say yes we do and I so
maybe we are maybe just as an example
maybe we want to say if you are if
someone who is a citizen of the
jurisdiction like in other words if it's
a if it's the town of Londonderry let's
say if if the if some board in
Londonderry is going to be talking about
a citizen of Londonderry then they have
to give some notice or if it's the
county maybe the county of Rockingham or
whatever but that's my concern
you need to add not only a citizen of
say Londonderry or but you need to add
an employee of Londonderry as well
because we just had a horrendous
thing happen in Londonderry so sure so
no in other words I think I support the
motion to retain just because it it
sounds like we this is something that
has some Merit but we need to work on
the sort of the parameters of it so I'm
I'm going to vote in support of the
motion to retained
um Mr uh Mr chair can I assume that
because of Representative Alexander's
enthusiasm he's volunteering to chair
this upcoming
I I think there's another what I sort of
I think I heard that too good we're in
agreement once again I will say there's
another subcommittee on lead I also
volunteered a chair so if somebody else
wants a chair committee I'm definitely
willing to spread the wealth there I'm
happy to do it if oh all right I may
regret it but um I'll do it so he
doesn't all right with everything job
we'll uh we'll we'll uh chair the
subcommittee all right so are we ready
anybody else have anything else to say
on the motion yes representative church
just just one more thing I I'm uncertain
on the on the retain and mostly because
when when I came away from that
Committee hearing was that there's a lot
of activity that happens with
um behind closed in in closed hearings
at the Town level that
um never see the light of day and that
that forcing the disclosure of just the
mere discussion of somebody's
potential
um
you know misbehavior or whatever you
might say and having to notice that
would cause that initial process that
that uh you know uh select boards and
other things take uh out into the open
in a way that is actually
counterproductive to the reputation you
know and protection of of the person
being subject so uh that does that was
my biggest concern coming away and I
feel like I'm not sure that that that
would be resolved through the retainer
all right
um no anyone else have any anything to
say on it all right so the motion before
us then is a motion to retain House Bill
652 uh that's the clerk to call the role
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Anders
rep testerman yes RIP Stapleton yes
reptrip yes rep Grayson yes clerky tab
votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith yes
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep Eden
rep page Brett Macbeth yes
rep Brennan yes rep lonza yes rep Manos
yes repturer no
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 19-1
representative
she has graciously volunteered to lead
the subcommittee that well
yes there's time for that
all right now on to our last and
favorite Bill uh the amendments to House
Bill 533 and I will recognize myself
to uh move uh otpa and specifically move
Amendment
uh
20230739 and ask if there is a second I
would second that please all right
motion's been made and seconded and I'm
gonna actually ask uh representative uh
Perez if she would speak to uh the
amendment
the original bill
um when we had all the testimony I felt
very strongly about this bill in favor
of the bill at the time because I felt
as though we needed we had so many
people coming representing
teachers and administrators and on and
on and on and I mentioned at that time
that we really had no one to represent
the children and the parents and this
might possibly equal the playing field
so
I initially was a little disappointed
with the amendment but then after
speaking to
um people about it I now support it
because
um it at least will help because I know
in my town there's a lot of information
that is trying to be obtained about
different things going on and the 91 A's
are just not working so different things
are trying to be filed with the
doe and now
um teachers and administrators have big
lawyers and big unions behind them the
parents and the children do not so I
think this too will help I was very
impressed with the testimony today from
the um investigator I actually spoke
with him outside and a couple of things
that were being said were misinterpreted
being misinterpreted when he talked
about one percent he was not talking
about one percent of teachers he was
talking about one percent of those
um problems that were brought to the doe
one percent of those not one percent of
the whole teacher population the other
thing that was brought up by one of the
Union Representatives is that 91 A's
would would help in this but that's he
brought up that I that that is not
really true because 91 A's cannot you
cannot obtain Personnel files with 91a
so I I really would like to see us move
this forward so that playing field is
equal and that the investigator can do
his job
granted
it may only be one
but you need to if it's only one you
still need to protect the child from
that one thank you
um anyone else wish to speak to 533
yes representative page yeah um I don't
know if this is going to be the
appropriate time but I'll speak against
just it might be the appropriate time to
discuss it now in terms of what um my
concerns with the amendment and the
underlying bill yeah yeah I mean
we had a colleague last term who
frequently
um
talked about a constituent who gave him
some good advice and it was his plumber
named Stan and he said when you go to
Concord don't do anything that's
unnecessary anything you don't have to
do
I'm I'm worried that that's what we're
doing here that we are giving excessive
power to the administrative state
and that concerns me from for a couple
of reasons um I don't believe that this
is necessary
we we had we started with HB 533 and
it seems to me that the DOA doe and the
Department of Justice are
working something out that problem has
been solved and now I'm worried that
with this amendment we're concentrating
power in
essentially one investigator with no
guard rails on that um
and he's has the authority
to investigate
for example
um
conduct prohibited under the banned
Concepts bill which is
courts have held that's a vague loss so
it concerns me that we might have that
much power concentrated through the
subpoena power with one person
interpreting a law that's incredibly
vague in terms of being able to subpoena
this as we mentioned there were some
other things about not being in the
guardrail of a usual subpoena issue the
amendment does talk about carrying out
an investigation now so let me change
that
um but you know the other point to
Stan's rule is the investigator said he
was having success he was able to solve
the problems
through his you know gumshoe detective
work I guess
um he he mentioned that he was worried
about a problem that he saw I believe
down the road
um the other thing that sort of two
other things and I'll shut up because
it's late but
um is is the timing of this the
investigator we had here said he'd been
asking
for 10 years for subpoena power
in 2018 we had the education educator
code of conduct
and in 2023 this is the first time
according to the doe lawyer that they
have asked this legislator legislature
for subpoena power
it just it seems weird in my my view in
the timing you know if it was that
pressing of a problem you know why the
delay
and and the context while I know
we were told at the beginning of the
hearing it's it's not political and and
this is not a political comic but the
context I think was brought to bear in
terms of
the teacher who testified
um about the former teacher about how
educators are operating now the
pressures that they feel the fears that
they have
um whatever those motivations are or not
I'm not speculating but they're they are
real and so I do worry in addition to
that
we're adding fuel to that sort of
context
um but but I do the biggest
issue I I have is concentrating that
amount of administrative power where no
other state does this
in one investigator who us has oversight
over a vague law
thank you
anyone else uh yes representative De
Lorenzo thank you Mr Claire um you know
my overall impression of the bill and
today's hearing
I was somewhat
um
concerned
because it felt like
the investigator was running the entire
department
and I don't believe that that's the case
um
and so I felt that
HB 533 is kind of a tentacle of the
divisive concept you are in the budget
trailer hb2 and
I was concerned that
the amendment charges the New Hampshire
Human Rights Commission as a state
agency with authority over these cases
over the complaints and we know that the
Human Rights Commission has bottlenecks
in their case management
the most recent update on cases on the
atrc website is 2018. there is no data
for a
2019-2022 so I don't even know what the
capacity is for the Human Rights
Commission to
hear these bills
now
I think I also recognize that
the commissioner uh Mr Edo blue
um
he wrote an op-ed
in April
and
he wrote about
a 70 page
um parcel of
material from parents and Educators that
he felt
was objectionable and
and possibly
um in violation of the um divisive
Concepts Act
so when the folks who introduced
um the bill from the
Department of Education the ones that
gave testimony they said it wasn't about
the commissioner out of blue but I I
think it is uh the fact that you know he
has been a pop in public
um he has released information about the
70 pieces of um 70 pages of information
uh given to him by parents and
um students
and he
the commissioner
because he had those 70 pieces of
information felt that the department
deserved to have subpoena power thank
you
anyone else uh yes representative
Stapleton
thank you Mr chair um
thank you representative page for your
comments and I
picked up on the 10 years
asking for The subpoena power that's an
interesting
fact um
two things
it takes a long time to pass bills here
many terms many years
I've had one of mine that's lingering
going on the third term and I know
there's other folks that have had
multiple terms beyond that to get bills
passed
good bills
um
even good Bills take a long time
and
far as
the the Human Rights Commission goes if
they've got a severe backlog how can
they investigate
I would think that
subpoena power would be enabling
to get information
so that we can determine the truth of
the matter
and and to get into the truth might
actually be
exculpatory as well as accusatory
so um
I think that if they've been looking for
that power for 10 years it's not linked
directly
to the divisive Concepts just happens to
fall in a timing sense that they both
come together in the same term year
um
I heard the investigators say that
they've been able to get information
with a lot of work and but it's getting
tougher
and it could be under a political
environment and such a divisive issue as
the divorce of Concepts law that we
could run into obfuscation
and hindrance in getting information
so I would see that value of subpoena
even greater now than otherwise and so I
would support the otpa
representative yes
uh sure go ahead
with all due respect uh representative
Stapleton you might have missed heard
what representative page said the 10
years referred to the amount of time
that the investigator has been here but
the um the Department's Council said
this is the first time that they have
asked for subpoena power they have not
asked for subpoena power before nor
would they have to since the Department
of Justice
has subpoena power and provides legal
counsel to them so
um it would be uh
Superfluous for them to have had the
need for subpoena power so
the 10 years referred to the amount of
time that the investigator
investigator has been here
my again I I look at this and
I wonder why there are no limits
established at all in terms of when in
any process
a subpoena is issued is it issued after
any preliminary investigation or is it
at the beginning as an attempt to um
uh
I don't know what the technical term
would be for it but to kind of look
around and see if we can find some
problems
um who is subject to a subpoena is it
only those people who are in fact uh
covered under the code of responsibility
in the department
what about parents what about children
none of that is is established and
um
uh in in the language it is uh very much
of a free-for-all and
um
I
I can't imagine that we as legislators
want to support an effort to just say oh
sure okay subpoena power what does it
mean because to me and I would imagine
to each of us subpoena power is really
something pretty significant and there
ought to be guidelines there ought to be
ground rules there ought to be
limitations and there ought to be a
clear demonstration that there's a need
for the subpoena power and if there is
fine they get it and they could get it
from the attorney general
in no time they couldn't get it from the
human relations Commission in no time
because the human relations commission
can't do anything in no time
um but they could from the attorney
general and um
uh
I'm really
uncomfortable in any Department without
regard
to who the Commissioners I would be
uncomfortable with the liquor department
I would be uncomfortable with the
transportation department I would be
comfortable with the Department of
administrative services having subpoena
power that isn't Limited in any way
because I care about privacy and I care
about due process and I don't think this
language supports either of those thank
you representative Turner
yeah thanks Mr chair so I have three I
went into this sort of with an open mind
this morning but I came away with sort
of three what I think are fairly strong
reasons that I opposed this
um the first and again stop me because I
know this may not be within my purview
you know is the question of a is it
germane to the original Bill and B does
it belong in this committee I know both
of those things are probably out of my
you know scope but but I will say the
original Bill spoke specifically about
human rights violations
and bringing things to the Human Rights
Commission whether the department of Ed
could do that on behalf of others
the testimony we heard today basically
talked about almost everything but the
human right they sort of it seemed like
people were trying to go around the
concept of of you know the the divisive
concerts and human rights violations
um to say this is about safety or it's
about buses or you know and they clearly
said it's in the entire code of conduct
is what's falling in so it's way wider
than the original bill so again I don't
know if I'm allowed to make that point
but it feels like this doesn't really
belong it I am assuming that bill was
before us because it was a Human Rights
Commission sort of Bill and this feels
very much like something that the
department of educate or the education
committee uh committee on education
should should hear and then overall the
question of
um so that was the first place basically
Jermaine and right for this committee
second uh echoing a lot of things that
we heard about limitations and process
it feels like this would better be done
as a bill
put together and most likely assigned to
the committee on education you know
which would build out theoretically all
of those things that
um the licensing boards have around
their subpoena power like a process and
limitations and what time in the
investigation can you make issue a
subpoena whereas this seemed totally
open-ended that was number three and
then the Third
was and this was something we heard in
our original testimony on the first bill
is that the Attorney General's office
can already do this on behalf of the
um the Department of Education
um that was for
bringing a complaint to begin with this
is now about issuing a subpoena but we
heard again today that the AG's office
has the power to do this and that the
the Department of Health and Human
Services
um when if they need to subpoena someone
goes through that channel and that seems
more appropriate so for those three
reasons I think that that this is really
not the right right place or the right
scope to be doing this as an amendment
representative staple
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Smith for the clarifying
information
I stand corrected and I thank you very
much and I apologize for the
misunderstanding
um beyond that my question was
who issues The subpoena who approves it
and representative trurer just related
that the AG's office has that capability
does a court also have the capability as
well as the AG and either one we're
going to rely on established Protocols
of
um of process and how to issue or if to
issue these things uh whether it's a
preponderance of evidence or a probable
cause
um and maybe these sort of technical
aspects are already covered under
existing law and procedure that's a
question
so um so let me let me speak to that
first of all let me just address the
issue that you raised representative
uh
the point you raise I I I you know I
there's they certainly are not frivolous
points the points that you raise about
the about the germanous issue I guess
what I would say to that is
both the clerk and the speaker
looked at the question of whether this
was Jermaine or not and they came to the
conclusion as related to me
yes it's Jermaine so that so that it's
within the jurisdiction of this
committee to hear it but it's different
enough from the original bill that you
should have a separate hearing which is
the reason we had this separate hearing
this morning so I I guess what I would
say that determination has kind of been
made above my pay grade yeah and I
acknowledge that as well so so that um
but but the second point I would make is
with regard to uh representative
stapleton's point is is this I think
it's really important
that everyone understand the way
subpoenas work first of all in terms of
are there limitations on this on the
Commissioners if it's the commissioner
not some investigator the commissioner
that has the authority to issue subpenas
now he may delegate that I'm not
suggesting he can't delegate it but it's
the commissioner that has the authority
and it the the amendment says a
commissioner is authorized to issue
subpoenas for persons relevant documents
and relevant items relevant bear in mind
relevant that's one limitation whenever
the commissioner has reason to believe
that a violation of the code of conduct
for educators has occurred so it has to
be relevant documents or relevant
information
when there is reason to believe and so
now the question comes up well is that
does that have any meaning or can the
commissioner just go out and do what he
wants and the answer to that is yes it
has meaning because
neither The subpoena power that is great
that would be granted under this bill
nor any subpoena power whether it's the
attorney general or any or the oplc or
any agency or or
um or even a court or I'm sorry a
litigant in court they may be able to
issue subpoenas but those subpoenas are
not self-enforcing so if somebody if you
you get a subpoena
you can you can basically tell the
person that gave you the subpoena that
that's very nice I'm gonna move I'm
gonna move to quash The subpoena in
court I'm I'm not going to comply with
that subpoena and the only way to have
it enforced is for the Department of
Education in this case or the Attorney
General to go to court and get a court
order saying you Mr respondent who has
been subpoenaed you will
you will comply with the subpoena or
you'll be held in contact that's
basically what they're saying or if it
turns out that the subpoena that that
the court finds there was no reasonable
basis to issue The subpoena or The
subpoena is over broad or the evidence
that's asked for is not relevant the
court will then quash The subpoena in
whole or in part so it's really
important to understand that
the the way when you when the when a
subpoena is issued that doesn't mean
that the Department of Education or for
lack of a better term people with guns
are coming out to somebody's to the
subpoenaed party's place and say
you're giving me this stuff right now or
you're coming with me right now that
does that's not what a you know subpoena
is not a search warrant or an arrest
warrant it simply says
you provide this information
and if you object to providing the
information you make move to quash The
subpoena in court and only the court can
order that it be provided on penalty of
if you don't do it then the court could
hold you in contempt so anyway that's uh
yeah but yes representative mcbeath
so just to follow what we're saying
I was so concerned I have hit this from
our rights are privately okay we in the
answer we just passed the prostitution
of London of course
in New Hampshire and government
the service shall be made on purpose who
are not right
and the people that are going to be
served are whoever the commissioner or
leads has reasonably may have violated
the code
is a super support because like you say
yeah the person that served the subpoena
they can go and try to wash it but the
testimony with this morning and if I
read the bill there are no there's no
ground to wash it because we don't have
any limits to the commissioner's power
it doesn't happen it's whenever in when
it whatever he thinks or she thinks is
reasonable I mean so how are you going
to squash and supreme this is more than
the attorney generals or whatever of our
state of they can't just there's no
basis this law just that if they if they
think it's going to help them proceed in
an investigation the investigation
doesn't have to be started okay it's
just then they can get it and so yeah
you're right you can of course but what
I'm asking it please let's put in the
due process and the limits that tell
what the commissioner can get this is
just uh I would not give this to anybody
um
all of us it's not just teachers or
licenses it's everybody
um and and again we have no there's no
way to find it because it doesn't say
the commissioner has to have established
XYZ before they put subpoena is going to
get the information or it needs to be
within this ground
or this or the person that's not on
isopy they have to have so many
please let's put
let's see what our friends have been
testified after you know the presenters
and let's let's provide some due process
comments to make sure that our health to
correct privacy
I guess I just have to say to respond I
I don't see any due process issues
whatsoever here this is this is sort of
really sort of standard language that
the Attorney General suggested putting
in reasonable costs so when you say
there are no limits so the commissioner
issues The subpoena for Teacher X to
provide or or the school district to
provide records on teacher X
um and and the school district objects
and says uh you know and moves to quash
and the and the so it now goes to court
and the judge says to the commissioner
what's your basis for issuing this
subpoena for these records for for
Teacher X and the commissioner says uh
you know I heard an art I heard an art a
news article on TV uh that there's a lot
of problems with uh with uh teachers uh
exercising too much force against their
students and so you know I thought I'd
issue The subpoena to find out if
teacher X is doing that the judges is
not only going to quash The subpoena but
is going to impose uh attorney's fees
against the Chief Justice when you you
you know a lot about law I don't you
know I'm just an attorney that went back
to practice after my kids went to
college but what I'm saying is I see
here when it says I the commissioner of
Education can send a subpoena to me and
there's nothing nothing here that says
how I'm going to quash that or how I'm
going to pay for the attorney to help me
quash that to figure out all that stuff
I'm telling you this this is dangerous
this is dangerous to everybody that's
sitting here
representative Perez
I think we've lost sight
of
what the intent here is the intent here
is to protect
children
not to protect you and me not to protect
anybody but children and I have listened
in the past three months that I've been
here
waiting for people to speak up
for the children and I keep hearing it
squashed this has been going on for
years the reason why it is more
important right now is because over the
past three years parents have finally
seen what is going on in the schools
because of Zoom they have issues the
reason why Frank edova put out that
thing is that information is because he
has an overwhelming number of of
complaints about human rights I went to
school board meetings and saw parents
crying because their children their even
their their handicapped children had
rashes on their mouth bleeding because
of mass because they drooled that to me
was a human rights violation that is why
it is important now
we all we want to do is protect the
children years ago I have a 43 year old
daughter I was on the school board in
Hollis Brookline I voted against
something my daughter's sixth grade
teacher would not allow her to go to the
bathroom because of me because of me
this has been going on for years if we
can protect one child by this it is
worth it we need to protect the children
the parents need a way of doing that
they don't have the the parents Union to
to help them these kids are being hurt
and I don't mean that physically but I
mean kids are being hurt it's been going
on for years it's worse now it is time
to do something for these children
you're worried about a lawsuit against
you or you or you what about the kid and
if it takes three years and that's what
it's hat taking for parents to get some
resolution what happens to that kid in
the meantime what have you done to that
child because of what you're worried
about worry about the kids I'm sorry I'm
angry
are there anyone else wish to be heard
uh representative
the
hello and listening to all this this
of all I've
a lot of people that got up opposed
everything
um so I first of all think um we gotta
our educators are out there to take care
of our children
they are they are they are trying to
educate them the best that they know but
you know there are times I mean I'm sure
there are times that some children get
unruly but you know what then they're
then they're dealt with and sent to the
principal or whatever they need to do
you know the thing is we got to think of
our Educators too people are not going
to go into this field
to care for our kids and to teach our
kids and for us to continue to keep our
our children here in New Hampshire we're
going to think about what we're doing
here where we came here to represent New
Hampshire
and we're also trying to represent our
our Educators as well as our students
okay and we got to think about the
parents I think if we give too much
um this um subpoena power the big thing
is first of all when we um did listen to
the first uh the detective talking about
or he was a detective pardon me uh
Richard Farrow he gave the one percent
now
um I know right away when representative
Brennan asked about what about the one
percent she's asked him about it and he
did not say it was not educators
about the educated he he never came back
and said nothing about it not he was
able to at that point retract his
statement and go into that he did not
so I think that I think we need to think
about the whole picture what we listen
to today
and also
um thinking about you know we don't want
to give people too much power
I mean we are here to help to make those
decisions but we also got to think about
our Educators as well I know as I say I
believe in our Educators I've had three
grown children now they all went through
the school system and in Goffstown they
then went on to college and have done
well and this is what we need to think
about you know is to continue to yes I
am concerned also about children and I
because I work in a labor and delivery
field I would not be bringing children
continuing to do that if I'm not
concerned about children and but at the
same time we also need to stand up for
what's right thank you anyone else wish
to be heard on HB 533 uh yes
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair um
that was interesting about your
explanation about how subpoenas work
it sounds as though it's not unlike a
dispute procedure
if you contest or disagree with the
subpoena
and you're going to go to court to hear
it then the clock stops until a judge or
the court makes a decision
I think that's a nice process to have
just like it's nice to have dispute
um to protect uh people uh against uh
unfair
uh inquiry or action
relative to the service I see that in
the amendment
um sub B and C provide for two
circumstances a service made on
licensees and certified individuals by
certified mail
or with or by hand
um and then see service made on persons
who are not licensees or certified
individuals
are in accordance with procedures and
fee schedules of the Superior Court
so it's it's not like that unlicensy
unlicensed people are non-certified or
not don't have any protection against
the subpoena power
um because there's a direct link to the
Superior Court
that's just my observation right or
wrong but it seems like that was a
thoughtful addition in the in the
amendment
yes representative tour that this is
more of a newbie question I guess
um
uh the idea of giving the commissioner
of Education sort of a new broad power
that other departments don't have
without having that concept go before
the education
Committee just seems odd to me is I know
this is the last day and there's
probably no time and this is probably no
process for it is there any way for the
the committee on education to weigh in
on something like this before it
proceeds
given the time I think that would be you
know that would be difficult I mean we
could have you know on the floor I
suppose that we we uh when the bill gets
to the floor but I think it probably
would be
um would be difficult to do that at this
point but you know the one thing you
said I think when you say that I think
it's really important to understand
the Attorney General
indicated to me because that was one of
my questions to the attorney general to
do other agencies have subpoena power
and he sent me back an email said you
know listing a bunch of agencies now he
he did say many of those agencies that
used to have their own subpoena power
are now under the oplc and it's there
it's the oplcs to Pina power but it's
not true
that we would be giving the education
department a subpoena power that no
other agency has mode in fact most of
them do have it even even though I think
this is another important part even
though
the Attorney General is sort of for lack
of a better term the super you know uh
law enforcer if you will the Attorney
General can can basically get involved
in with with with the enforcement
activities of any agency and could could
issue subpoenas in connection with that
but none notwithstanding that
many agencies have their own subpoena
power because generally unless there's
some you know unless there's some really
huge overriding public interest the
Attorney General's office doesn't get
involved in if you know if a teacher's
if there's a claim that a teacher needs
to be disciplined for one reason or
another it's usually the education
department that handles that as opposed
to the Attorney General's office and the
same is true if there's you know if some
if if uh somebody that's uh uh a barber
is you know is has violated some of the
conditions of the whatever the barber
code is it's usually I guess I think The
Barbers are under the oplc so it would
be the oplc as opposed to the attorney
general that would take care of those
kind of things all right I'll say I I do
wish they had appeared before us they
they the AG's office came for the
initial hearing on this bill when it was
in its former form and it would have
been great to have their input for this
too
yes representative Chester
there's as some superpower
they're not
I've avoided trying to get into this but
teachers
I read it I read a book by a guy by the
name of it was Hal or but anyway
if you look at teachers and if you look
at what the how they do in high in
college
there and and how the how they graduate
they have the lowest accumulation of SAT
scores of almost any major
yeah and she there's nothing it's not
hard to understand because
we've allowed and I thought it was a
great idea teachers to become astronauts
to become lawyers to become doctors and
everything else and that didn't used to
be true women
in the 60s were
pretty much left to their to be to being
a teacher
a librarian or a nurse or getting
married
but but that's changed the world has
changed so
the people left to be teachers
are not the biggest and brightest group
of people we tend to think they are some
of them are but they're really not
collectively
so we have to be careful when we're
using them as an example of of what how
to decide what we're going to do you
know we need to realize these are just
regular people
they walk down the street and and and we
they may may need to be subpoenaed there
are bright ones among them they're the
head of the uh the AC aft and the uh and
so on but yeah they're not the brightest
bunch of people and we we need to
realize that we're we're putting trying
to put some rules in the reason we need
them is because they've changed so
yes representative Smith
thank you very much first
um representative testerman I'm
wondering if the same thing could be
said about legislators
might be
um but I thank you I thank you for your
comments um
I I this amendment has no criteria no
criteria for when a subpoena can be
issued as written the amendment allows
the Department of Education to issue a
subpoena in the absence of a formal
written complaint
just the subpoenas seems to come first
I don't think the absence of such
criteria before the issuance of the
subpoena is appropriate it also allows
the department to issue subpoena in the
absence of an investigation formally
being open where the department has
initially determined that a possible
violation of the code of conduct has
occurred it just says if the
commissioner thinks that maybe there's
been a problem then they issue a
subpoena
I I think subpoena is a pretty darn
important and pretty powerful and I
don't see them being something that
would be issued at the whim of anybody
even me
I mean I shouldn't be allowed to issue
even though I know everything there is
to know except what bill I was talking
about earlier
um it's they're important limitations on
subpoena powers and there should be if
you look at the statute about oplc
they cannot issue a subpoena until an
investigation has commenced and the oplc
is the example that the chair has given
on a number of occasions about Well
everybody's doing it including the oplc
there always should be checks on the
ability to issue a subpoena usually
there's a lawsuit there's Discovery
um there's you know the whole you know
laws against discrimination none of that
is in this this is it seems to be people
going on a fishing Expedition which
doesn't mean that it should be governed
by Fish and Game it shouldn't it should
be governed by the Attorney General's
office because the Attorney General one
hopes is fully cognizant of the reasons
that you have to have limitations on
subpoenas I do not worship teachers I do
not worship teachers unions I I don't
think that they're any different than
anybody else and they should be subject
to the same standard and the same
accountability as anybody else that's
part of why I
I believe that nobody should have
immunity then why don't we give them
that direction in this law I mean this
has been around it's been sitting around
you seem to know an awful lot about how
it ought to be several people in this
room know it seem to know how it should
be
we should be able to add that in as an
amendment now it may need to be a we're
going to may need to have to hold this
to study it and put it in this fall but
yeah we I'd be willing to do that with
you representative testerman if you want
to hold this until the fall to see if we
could come up with something that made
sense because I think everybody should
be held accountable but they should be
held accountable within the restrictions
of
um of the democratic process small D
Democratic process and accountability
that all public officials should have I
agree with you I it's just we've been
letting this thing sort of slide and we
can't do that anymore
yeah
right other comments on this yes uh
representative Tripp thank you Mr chair
you know I've been like Mr testerman
representative desperate again sitting
here quiet a lot I'm trying to
incorporate some of the conversation
that's been uh
held here but uh there's been a lot of
talk about uh there's this is so wide
open and if you look at line 10 of the
amendment it says for the purpose of
carrying out investigations
you know it seems that you know that is
if you are carrying out an investigation
and someone asks well what's the
investigation then you know obviously
you've begun an investigation
you know I don't know what the criteria
for uh uh registering it is but uh it
seems that this this puts a a little bit
of a reins in some of the power of the
Department of Education because you know
uh if you have an investigation open
and if you need a subpoena in order to
gather information
then
it's necessary they have the power to
to issue a subpoena
you know I know that uh I've had some
uh
conflicts with my school board
you know about if you were to ask him a
question about something you know their
response is always
why do you need to know that
you know and uh the it seems like uh I
wish that I had a subpoena issuing
power sometimes because getting an
answer of them is very difficult and I
I'm not I understand why you know the
investigators said that uh uh this would
have been handy for 10 years or so
because it's a
being told that or asking a question
only to be answered with what do you
need to know that is is uh is not
productive and investigating
now so uh
I believe that uh the uh the amendment
also says there's a reason to believe
there's a violation well if there's a
reason to believe and he's been assigned
uh to carry out an investigation
and he's asked questions and he's got no
answers then
this is the answer
thank you president Morgan yes
just uh hopefully this will be a couple
of comments um one is uh
wonders there's a lot of concerned about
uh parents in education so the code of
conduct and I was just sneaking a peek
at it actually says hardly anything
about interactions between parents it's
all about
Educators interaction with the students
and other Educators so there's a
nothing in the dress is wondering some
of the issues that other committees have
been struggling with but um so it
doesn't really solve that issue one way
or the other but it does give the
commissioner pretty broad power to go in
a fishing Expedition
um perhaps on even if there's no actual
code of conduct violation against a
teacher who he or she doesn't uh doesn't
approve of but the second comment is um
there's well this bill came with a
minimal fiscal note they conclude that
Department of Education thought there'd
be no uh additional costs so that's why
it's a late Bill and we're not dealing
with it a month ago but um as amended
there's probably pretty significant
costs and a we don't know what they are
B we have no funding mechanism for it so
that
could be termed an unfunded mandate but
um certainly the cost of this amended
bill is much higher than the cost of the
original Bill and that's uh probably
cause for concern right there thanks any
other comments
oh yes representative thank you for
taking my my comment
um you know as we listen we've been
listening to this about maybe half of
the day and I think that the state of
New Hampshire does not act alone on
educational
um
Administration what about the feds what
do the feds say about you know New
Hampshire's commissioner using subpoenas
um
is there a danger of that
doing so could violate
American with Disabilities Act if the
student is disabled or the teacher is
disabled so you know I think that more
study needs to go into this Bill thank
you all right any other comments all
right yes
I believe I I just very briefly
I get the point that we could quash a
subpoena through the court I mean with
with respect but there's huge
transaction costs associated with that
does someone actually have to do that
and I think we may sit here and say a
subpoena might be a dead letter compound
sand but I think maybe someone who
received that subpoeno is on the
receiving end of that from a government
agency might be concerned the other
point I think is worth making is to my
understanding we would be the only state
that would allow this to occur at this
phase that during or in the course of
Investigation whatever the exact
languages I believe it may be
permissible in the context of a hearing
where someone's license is up for uh
termination or revocation
but this seems to
be ahead of or behind or depending how
you look at it what other states are
doing I'm not sure where you get that
from representative page I'm not I I I
just I don't know the I'm not I'm not
saying that there you know that all
other states allow this I just don't
know but I'm not sure it's uh I'm not
sure
I mean where are you getting it that no
other states have this I I said I
believe and I think we had testimony
from one of the um
uh I can't remember who it was when I
asked that question I thought it was
maybe Mr Hawkins who's here and I
thought all he said was he didn't he
just didn't know I mean if I'm wrong if
I'm wrong on that Mr Hawkins and you do
know then please that you know educate
us
so was it correct I mean so is it
correct to say that at least right now
you don't know
so we don't okay we don't no that's all
I'm saying yeah we don't know we don't
know so I but I don't think it's fair to
say that you know that other other
states don't have this we just don't
know but but isn't it important these
are questions that are so important to
know before we move forward
why well I mean not just do other states
do it but just this the whole due
process and narrowing the scope and
putting guardrails on and how you're
going to quash it what is the criteria
to cross it all that type of stuff
yeah representative Wallace thank you Mr
chair colleagues the way I read the bill
um as representative Tripp pointed out
uh for the purpose of carrying out
investigations pursuant to the code of
conduct of New Hampshire Educators that
sets some pretty
uh well-defined boundaries the way I
read it again I'm not an attorney and
and this is also been approved and ruled
germane by the speaker and the clerk of
the of the house so this is the right
committee for this bill to be heard at
this particular time
um and uh the educator did excuse me the
investigator did say that this would be
used at the end of the process should it
be needed and that in his words and I
quote we will not be casting this out as
a fishing Expedition or as a fishing net
if you will
um it's only going to be these
situations and the anecdote he used was
uh there was three principles involved
in a particular investigation he was
conducting to provided some help one
didn't and that's when they would
actually exercise
um the option to seek The subpoena to
get that information
um I trust our investigations I I trust
our state police to do the right thing
and I trust this individual he's been
stay true before in some capacity for 40
years I don't believe he's the problem
other any other comment on the on the
amendment so let me ask let me ask you
this I I mean I'm I'm clearly reading
the room that there's going to be a
strong disagreement on whether the Bills
should pass my my initial question
though is do you want to have a roll
call vote on the amendment or can we
just do that by show of hands and then
we will have a roll call vote on the on
the uh on the bill itself
what do you what to say
it does you know this this amendment
replaces the the building
okay all right then let's have her all
right so anybody else have anything else
they want to say
all right seeing nothing so we'll take a
roll call vote on Amendment
0739h2 House Bill 533 and I would ask
the clerk to uh please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes wrap Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rap trip
yes rep Grayson yes clerk your tab boots
yes repress
rep Smith
no reporgan no Rap De Lorenzo no prep
Eaton no rep page Brett Macbeth no rep
Brennan no rap lonza no rap Manos no
repter no
chairman Lynn yes
motion Bales 10 to 10.
Mr chair all right
all right so Christmas sales is Miss
Jared I'd like to make a motion because
the underlying Bill obviously there was
a reason for an amendment right uh to
replace all
and there seems to be some agreement
that we could come up with something if
we pow-wowed long enough to
come up with something I move that we
retain the bill
and
see what representative testerman and
Smith can come up with right is there a
second
is there is is there a second
by representative Tripp all right
anybody want to
speak to
the motion to retain
Ed
yes representative
I I think this bill should
um be reintroduced as a separate piece
of legislation that my guess would be
given to a different committee so no all
right anyone else wish to speak to the
motion to before before us now there's a
motion to retain
seeing none all right let's have a roll
call on the motion to retain
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes rep chap yes rap Grayson
yes clerkata votes yes rep Perez
rep Smith
rep Horgan no
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton
rep page
Brett Macbeth yes rep Brennan
no
rap lonza no
rap Manos no
ripped her no
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes fourteen to six
all right
um
think
we are done
we're just right with this process
um
uh so don't forget uh everyone we are um
we are having that joint meeting with uh
child and family on the 28th at 2 30.
um
uh we may
I don't want to sort of lull you into
thinking that nothing's happening until
then uh I'm not I haven't scheduled
anything but we haven't these we're done
with our bills
I haven't gotten any Senate bills yet
but usually the
stop okay all right so uh so you know
what again the only other thing I would
say is if you're gonna be writing a
report please get it to me by the end of
the day tomorrow and when I say the end
of the day I mean if you do it in the
evening that's fine I completely
understand and
pardon
no tomorrow tomorrow yeah and um again
thanks everyone for being here and uh
for a for a a very uh civil and
reasonable discussion on things that I
know are are uh can be quite contentious
so thank you
yes we'll be meeting here we're meeting
here it'll be since it's since it's
their day to use the room they will sort
of be the
they'll be running the show so to speak
no I should be asking the judicial
branch to be providing that but I won't
do that
yeah I know